they finally got him
james o'keefe they got him he's banned
off twitter he's still on instagram
but twitter has permanently banned james
o'keefe they recently permanently banned
project veritas
and now they've come for james himself
and this work it's interesting
i think james is doing the right thing
here he's announced he's going to be
suing
twitter for defamation why twitter
claims the reason he got banned was for
operating multiple
fake accounts or something to that
effect and james says i didn't do that
that's a false statement to fact now
he's suing and i
and i wonder why no one's done this
before and it made me question some of
these other individuals there have been
people
very prominent who have been banned from
twitter and then twitter says they run
fake accounts
and then i'm like okay sue them because
they're clearly lying right and then
these individuals are like oh well you
know i'm not going to sue
so it makes me wonder this time james is
like now i'm soon
so i believe that james is telling the
truth this is a ridiculous man i don't
think he was doing anything
untoward on on twitter but they banned
him
so here we go interestingly we have more
james o'keefe news because he announced
he's going to be suing cnn
as well so the dude is uh
look veritas is going above and beyond
their their scope of work and
it's good they're literally fighting the
good fight
they are not only exposing the media for
their lies they're actually taking the
fight to the courts
and in one of their recent legal
victories the new york times the judge
ruled
that if the new york times wants to
claim they're writing fact-based news
but then they inject opinion
stands to reason they should be
informing their readers and thus
veritas won defeating emotion to dismiss
i gotta say watching all this stuff
james james o'keefe might be like
one of the only prominent leaders in my
opinion when it comes to conservatism
actually doing something
winning battles and challenging the
system so my respect we're going to talk
about all this but we actually have
interestingly perfect timing it's just
so weird this happens all the time
synchronicity we will we try to book
guests and we'll be like what's a good
date
and so we have the ex-founder of
wikipedia larry sanger would you like to
just give yourself a quick introduction
larry
sure um well i'm
what should i say i grew up in alaska
i all three of my degrees are in
philosophy um my claim to fame or infamy
is
is uh starting wikipedia
um i've worked on a long series of
uh non-profit and educational projects
and now i am
the the uh president of the
knowledge standards foundation we'll
talk about that i guess
ex-founder of wikipedia so suffice to
say you're not happy with the way things
went with wikipedia
yeah no i'm i'm also one of
uh wikipedia's leading critics now
interesting
i'm not happy with uh how it's gone
the reason i say it's it's interesting
timing is that there's there's an
overlap in the space of how wikipedia
operates
how fake news manipulates information
how big tech companies are banning
people so we'll get into all that larry
thanks for hanging out we got
ian he's chilling we do have ian
crossland and welcome to my
psychoactive experience otherwise known
as tim cast irl
magnets and i want to tell you about the
magnetic monopole
if you're not familiar it's a
theoretical or hypothetical magnet
that's not found in nature but it only
has
one pole and so it has a the magnetism
facing in one direction i think if we
can
master the magnetic monopole we'll have
levitation now ian
is a co-founder of minds.com as well yes
so this is uh this will be
this should be good we'll talk a lot
about the censorship and the fake news
and of course we've got lydia she's
chilling i am in the corner i'll just be
nodding along tonight because this is
way out of my wheelhouse but i'm really
excited to learn about all this stuff
my friends before we get started head
over to timcast.com and become
a member to get access to exclusive
members only segments of the show
yesterday was a hoot we had uh we had
jack murphy and sheamus coughlin from
freedom tunes
and at one point jack murphy said he
loved ian oh thank you jack
now if you want to see that you got to
go to tempest.com sign up
and uh we're we're working on the site
we're making it better you can see now
right at the top there's a members area
you can just click it we made it easier
for everybody to find
and we're building things out because
we're gonna be rolling out rolling out a
bunch of new content we're bringing in a
news editor a paranormal subject matter
editor
it's gonna be a lot of fun content new
shows we got a vlog already produced we
got we're gonna upload it make the new
channel it's gonna be fun
with your support it'll get even better
so do that but don't forget to like
share subscribe and if you're listening
on itunes or spotify
leave us a good review leave us five
stars it really does help and tell all
your friends how awesome this show is
and uh and thanks for being here we
broke a million subs last night and
everybody you guys rock
let's jump into this first story so
definitely we're going to get to
i want to you know get into the nitty
gritty of wikipedia because i have rag i
was basically ragging on wikipedia and
then you tweeted at me and i was like
yes let's talk about
you know wikipedia but we do have some
breaking news that i want to get into
first
from the rap twitter permanently
suspends project veritas's james o'keefe
o'keefe says he plans to sue the
platform for defamation following the
suspension
twitter permanently banned james o'keefe
thursday the project veritas founder
spent the preceding days posting videos
taken of a cnn employee
without that employee's knowledge in
keeping with his organization's practice
of coverted coverted re covertly
recorded content
copy editor guys but in violation of
twitter's policy
o'keefe who had over 900 000 followers
at the time of his suspension
told the rap that he plans to sue the
social media platform quote
the account you referenced james o'keefe
iii
was permanently suspended for violating
the twitter rules on platform
manipulation and spam
a twitter spokesperson confirmed as
outlined in our policy on platform
manipulation and span
you can't mislead others on twitter by
operating fake accounts
and you can't artificially amplify or
disrupt conversations
through the use of multiple accounts
that's an interesting statement to make
because now james could sue for
defamation assuming it's not true
the rep declined to elaborate on the
claim that o'keefe was running multiple
fake accounts
including how many he was running or how
they were used in a statement
o'keefe said i am suing twitter for
defamation because they said i
james o'keefe operated fake accounts
this is false
this is defamatory and they will pay
section 230 may have protected them
before
but it will not protect them from me the
complaint will be filed monday
that reminds me of uh watchmen you guys
have you seen the movie watchmen yeah
or read the comic at all i think i did
once just a little bit of it anyway
it just reminds me of when rorschach is
in prison and he's like i'm not trapped
in here with you
you're trapped in here with me and it's
not
a good one for one analogy but basically
they started to fight with somebody who
was looking for him well i shouldn't say
james is looking for a fight but ready
to win
a war yeah he only goes to war when he's
going to win that's
what i've learned about james o'keefe
he's been going to war he's been going
to battle i should say
to win this war so you may have heard he
sued the new york times oh yeah
now now he's also going to sue cnn so
here here's the next bit of this story
which will get us into the talk of
censorship and and fake news and things
like that
james is according to newsweek james
o'keefe to expand his war on cnn with
lawsuits more video
controversial undercover journalist and
scourge of the left so saith newsweek
james o'keefe appears to be waging a
full-scale war
on cnn that includes not only the
undercover videos he's known for
but also a series of planned lawsuits
against the news network and its anchors
over issues that may not even involve
him
or his non-profit organization o'keeffe
told newsweek he will soon sue
cnn and two of its journalists brian
stelter and anna cabrera
for defamation and report about twitter
permanently banning project vertos
the february segment featured cabrera
accusing veritas of promoting
misinformation and calling a group of
conservative actionists
activists none of which o'keefe says is
true
twitter reportedly banned project
veritas over an anti-doxing policy
after the group confronted a facebook
executive outside of his home
in the same february segment stelter
claimed project veritas violated
multiple rules
meanwhile o'keefe posted video of cnn so
this i think most people are familiar
with
here's a here's a statement from james
he said we are suing cnn
brian stelter and anna cabrera and we
are going to represent
others in defamation suits against cnn
we are going to launch a division for
lawsuits
o'keeffe told newsweek i wonder where he
got that idea i like that idea i believe
he
we uh brainchild of that here on the
show well his is a little different but
uh
when he was on the show we talked about
the people's defamation defense fund or
something
to that effect so when these news
outlets start writing fake stories
there is an advocate to protect you from
the media the smears
as we get into this uh the space where
everyone's a public figure
you know uh it becomes harder and harder
to sue for instance nicholas sandman in
the covington catholic case
they argued he was an involuntary public
figure because someone filmed him
standing on stairs
and now he was in the public spotlight
it's insane we've come to that point
where basically no one is protected
anymore so
if project veritas is doing it i'm
stoked this guy's
you know winning to win some battles
there's there's a a huge
need for it and um i uh
i can only say and that they eventually
um help give the same treatment to
wikipedia frankly there's been so many
people who have been defamed
by wikipedia um and there hasn't been
any recourse i i remember uh
back in 2006 i think it was or seven
something like that um john siegenthaler
senior um the father of john zegenthaler
jr
um i believe he's a co-founder of usa
today
or so uh something like that um
in the tennessean he was the the the
publisher or the editor
anyway very distinguished gentlemen
um elderly retired and
um he you know they had
essentially defamed him by saying that
he had
you know gone to live in
in the soviet union back in the day or
something like that
um and it was bad and it was totally
false
and he he basically criticized me over
the phone
back then um and i felt bad i really did
and it's like i took i took because
personal responsibility and that's
that's one of the things that that made
me realize that you know
real people are harmed by this sort of
thing
when did you uh so look you know i guess
in the context of of james and all this
yeah he's i think he's someone who has
seen the lies and the smears firsthand
yeah for a very long time sure
i mean so i went to wikipedia and i
looked up project veritas
and it says definitively they produce
deceptively edited videos
and i'm like what's the source for this
and i click it it actually links to like
24 different articles
the problem is the word deceptive is an
opinion not a statement of fact
but wikipedia is an encyclopedia
supposedly showing you
the facts so i think for james he just
finally was sick of it and said let's go
to war and start fighting back which he
is
i'm curious i mean that story about this
guy from here today that was that was
the first moment you realized that
you know defamation was occurring or oh
i i of course i knew
that there was defamation going on
before that but it's he really brought
it home to me because he was actually a
victim
and he was a distinguished old southern
gentleman
and and he was criticizing me personally
so that that's what really made it hit
home
it didn't matter at the time that i was
i was actually starting a competing
website i still took responsibility
for for wikipedia so
i don't i don't understand why james
hasn't launched a nuke against wikipedia
right now
it says on wikipedia project veritas
purpose disinformation wow
outright yeah there's a far right
activist group
the group produces deceptively edited
videos no
uh so i think this is that that
materially damages
his reputation um and and the thing is
wikipedia does that to a lot of people
now right and they're hiding behind
section 230 they're hiding behind that
that protection and there is absolutely
no recourse that anybody has
due to the legal framework in which
wikipedia operates
i've i've known about this for a long
time
you know and i just i i have
wondered you know how what what's gonna
actually what's it gonna take
to change and maybe it's somebody with
relatively deep
pockets and lots of rich friends
actually going after them in a in a big
way and you you don't seem particularly
well i haven't known you that long but
you don't seem particularly biased right
you're you're i think you tweeted in
defense of james o'keefe on about him
getting suspended
um uh sure well
in defense of him being suspended i'm
sorry i'm sorry in defense of his
uh of him yeah in relation to the
suspension saying james should not have
been suspended
well i i absolutely yeah i i think he
shouldn't have been
suspended just recently on twitter but i
mean i wouldn't agree that i'm
that i'm unbiased what i mean to say is
uh we all have our biases yeah but
you're not you're not
you don't appear to be a tribalist like
defending the conservatives
so that that's why i think it's
important to make the distinction we're
talking about what wikipedia was
supposed to be
okay um i'm i can only imagine what your
original vision for it was and how it
strayed from that
that's my opinion of what can you tell
us about it like when did you start it
how many of you were there and what was
the vision
right well um uh i i don't know how long
do you
want me to go into this because we have
a two-hour show
i'm thinking about it when you're 17
like where did it come from
okay well i won't go into too much
detail but i'll give you
because this is a big enough platform
probably a lot of people who are
listening to this have not
heard the story um so i'll just i'll
just tell it again
um basically i got to know jimmy wales
in the mid 1990s he ran a
discussion group for fans of inrant um
really oh yeah wow um and well he
used to be a hardcore objectivist
slash libertarian um and
well we can talk about that later
whatever um and and i actually
uh i got to know him a little bit i
wouldn't say that
we ever became friends but we were good
acquaintances and we were friendly
um and i actually met him in person a
couple of times
back in the mid 1990s and then about
i guess at the end of 1999 early 2000
um i was deciding what i was going to do
with this website that i had called
sanger's review
of y2k news reports oh wow
yeah um and uh
i made some proposals uh
and sent it out to different
acquaintances he was one and he said
why don't you come to work for me i want
to start this
free public contributed encyclopedia
built on a mo the model of
um like linux so open source
uh except it's not open source it's open
content and it gave me stuff to read
i said yes i mean this is like i
actually
have to answer your question dreamed um
about things that i could do with the
philosophy degree if i didn't want to
become
a professor which eventually i decided
not to do back in like 1996.
um so uh and one of them was
an encyclopedia editor and here
somebody's offering me the the
opportunity to start
my own encyclopedia and yeah it was
really cool
um so that was my job basically to start
something
he he had the domain name was called
newpedia and i organized
um a a group of hundreds of phds
and it was almost like organizing a
whole college really
because there were different departments
and there were quite a few different
people in the different departments and
so forth
but um i sort of
worked with these people and being
academics
they like things being very regimented
and top down
and that's the system that we ended up
with um negotiating with them we ended
up with a system that had seven steps
and it was a lot of work to get an
article through that system
so in the end um
we realized it actually i shouldn't say
in the end
close to the beginning actually we
realized we were
well agreed that there needed something
um we needed something to make it a lot
easier for people to contribute
just the average person so i cast around
different ways of of allowing other
people to contribute
and um i uh
eventually um a friend of mine and this
this was uh january 2nd of uh 2001
um he told me about wiki wiki software
the wiki wiki web that's the original
wiki
portland pattern repository it's a
repository of
software programming patterns
and then that same
concept of a sort of like a public
bulletin board anybody could write
anything they want and edit anything
and yet somehow magically it works okay
and he explained how and why it could
work
and i said wow this actually might be
a way we should try this out because the
software was free
so i that same evening i went
back and i think ben kovitz is the name
of my friend we
had had a mexican dinner um and in which
he explained all this to me
i went back um to my
apartment and wrote out a um
a one-page proposal to jimmy wales um
and said can you guys um
install the software for me to use and
and uh
it's a couple of days later that was
done and so i just went to
work like describing what a wiki
encyclopedia would be like
um and it would it changed
the culture it wiki wikis had been
around for six years before that so
there was already a sort of internet
culture surrounding wikis
so we had to sort of change that and
reappropriate
not just the software but also the um
the the culture for the purpose of
creating
an encyclopedia um and uh
i was just amazed that like after the
first
uh month despite a lot of people being
very
skeptical about um it possibly working
especially
the the relatively straight-laced um
phd uh editors of of newpedia
um they they didn't like the idea at all
and and sort of jimmy wales himself was
kind of in
in their corner in the beginning um
and i said well okay we're gonna just
we're gonna have to
relaunch this because originally it was
gonna be the new pedia wiki
right it was a different it was a a
different
um uh course of
uh or source of content for newpedia
that's what it was supposed to be
um and i said okay well if you guys
don't want it associated with the
newpedia brand then we'll just
we'll just uh relaunch it under its own
domain name and i came up with with
wikipedia we
registered that originally it was
wikipedia.com
because the whole enterprise was started
by bombus
bombus inc it doesn't exist any longer
um and they were a startup of the
uh of the old.com boom in the late 1990s
and
they were well-funded through ads
and then that basically the funding
disappeared it
even as wikipedia was taking off even
though in that first year
so basically in that in that first year
um everyone was amazed
at how well it was working even just
like a month
into it and people were just excited to
participate
and we observed after a few months
how google would spider all the articles
the new articles
in wikipedia and
the there was a sort of
like a a stair um
graph of the growth of wikipedia after
the google spider um
hit the site um there would be a bump
um in both activity on the site
and and just new people working on the
site
um and so it it looked like
a positive feedback loop and i thought
that that's just this can't be true it's
like too good to be true
but it was a it was truly a viral
phenomenon
um makes sense yeah the more articles
that get written
people search for things there's a
one-stop shop that has that subject so
google probably favored wikipedia as the
parent domain
and then whenever something got searched
for because wikipedia existed it treated
it probably like a news source
yeah you know you got it exactly that's
that's pretty much how it worked
um i don't know perhaps at some point
google
um like made some special decisions that
that um increased the overall
ranking of the wikipedia articles you
know the page rank
um algorithm was simpler back then
and and um who knows it doesn't it
doesn't really matter
i think in the beginning it was just a
lot of
excitement about the whole idea
bright-eyed bushy-tailed i guess
very very optimistic for sure i i'm i'm
i've been staring at this
project veritas wikipedia page
completely dumbfounded
it has their address why is the address
for project veritas publicly listed with
their their mailbox number
that's on wikipedia yeah right that's
insane that's weird
yeah i suppose they probably list
locations for other corporations too but
it's very clear what they're doing
they add methods hidden cameras video
manipulation funded by donors trust
a disinformation ngo it's very
the whole thing is just smearing project
franchises and i'll let you guys in
on some some new information project
veritas
has been i'll call it an upgrade
upgraded by newsguard
from proceed with caution red
exclamation point to
under review good so that doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to get
deemed credible by news newsguard but i
can tell you this
project veritas produces videos where
you can see someone's mouth moving
there you go yeah the new york times
says trust our source we won't tell you
who it is you can't see him you have no
idea who said this
and i love it when they say source is
familiar with
so-and-so's thinking it's like oh yeah
i'm familiar with the president's
thinking too because i watch cnn
does that make me a credible source
apparently to these people yeah and
i so i look at wikipedia and it's become
it's
it's very obviously a a political
machine at this point
politicians in congress edit it you can
you can go in and see the ipa addresses
there there's companies called
reputation management firms that you can
hire
anyone you can go higher if you want a
wikipedia page let's say you're
you know you're you're a senior level
manager at a company and you're like man
i want people to know who i am
you got five grand use contact a
reputation management firm
they'll do everything that needs to be
done from editing wikipedia to getting
the new sources created
to then be credible and make it look
like there's a grassroots efforts to
defend you if someone tries to get your
page deleted and they'll win
because when you've got an army of
unpaid wikipedia editors
versus a massive corporation getting
paid guess who's likely going to win
so at what point did you notice those
things larry
um it was very gradual to tell the truth
i mean we didn't let's put it this way
we knew when uh i think his name is
virgil griffith
um basically uh
published the identities of
people of organizations that
uh behind ip addresses that had
edited wikipedia this is back in like i
i don't know i want to say 2005. um
and uh the cia was among them
right and there were all kinds of
politicians
offices so we knew back then a long time
ago
that because wikipedia was already
in the top 50 or whatever it was
that they were going to start doing that
i think i didn't really
get an idea of just
how much the whole procedure
might be controlled by um
various powerful forces um until
uh just in the last like i'd say five
years
because it it really has
turned from
a well-meaning public service
aimed at at the neutral point of view as
as it was called as it still is called
but now
cynically um to a
slightly left-leaning reference
that was like in 2005 or so
and then a clearly biased but still
reference work in like 2010 and then
basically in the last four years or so
um
it's just been nothing but propaganda i
mean it's bad
at least when it when it uh goes into
political topics and anything that has
any sort of socio-political
um aspect to it um and
i i want to add this also in to support
what you're saying um if you just
think about it and this is not to say we
don't have evidence
that this is the case also but it just
makes sense
look it's like uh ranked 13
by um alexa.com
the the website ranking service um
and it used to be it used to be in the
top
five so they've dropped a little bit but
it's still huge
right and why
wouldn't given that so much
of of uh warfare
and spying that goes on is is
digital now right
it's it's silly to think that that
um people would not be plowing
enormous amounts of money into it
figuring out the way that the wikipedia
game is played
and just manipulating it and the thing
is it's all
it's a black box even the people who are
thoroughly familiar with how the system
actually works
there are lots of decisions that are
made between
the power players in the system that we
have no way of knowing about because the
people
involved are anonymous and it's not
the decisions are not being made on the
website
i can uh uh my favorite way to prove the
the
brokenness the the failed state of
wikipedia
is with uh by going to the article man
so i am not showing you these articles
in any way to make a statement
about the politics of gender identity or
gender ideology
i am simply showing this because there
is
a contentious political issue in the
area of you know transgender uh spaces
and and gender ideology
between conservatives and uh and
liberals and progressives
i am not going to make an assessment on
that for the purpose of the segment i'm
going to show you wikipedia being broken
quite simply the first article we have
is man
wikipedia defines man as an adult male
human they say prior to adulthood a male
human is referred to as a boy
they do make exceptions for gender later
on in this paragraph but it says
definitively opening statement
a man a man is an adult human
adult male human let's go and see what
male
means male according to wikipedia is the
sex of an organism
that produces the gamete known as sperm
a male gamete can fuse the larger female
gamete or ovum in the process of
fertilization
a male cannot reproduce sexually without
access to at least one ovum from a
female
now i'd like to show you trans man trans
man according to wikipedia
definitively opening statement a trans
man is a man
who was assigned female at birth the
word man in this article trans man links
you back
to the first article which says a man is
an adult male human
now i am not saying any of this again
about the politics in any way
of transgender but how can wikipedia
simultaneously claim
that a trans man is a man but that a man
produces sperm
while admitting or acknowledging a trans
man does not
so it's it's a it's a broken feedback
loop of an of an
illogical assessment what happened is
on wikipedia there are various uh genres
i suppose
the science editors are adamant about
controlling their space in science
you will likely not find a hard
biological
you know evolutionary biologist or
biologist who's going to tell you
that male means anything other than this
gamete sperm or or something to that
effect however
because of the way that impacts
political ideologies
you then have political ideologues and
activists who dominate
the other space which would involve
gender ideology
they then assert a trans man is a man a
trans woman is a woman
however the science portion of wikipedia
does not agree and will not but because
there's more science editors in that
space
the activists can't change that article
if you have four activists and six
science writers the six science writers
will dominate the discussion
but in the activists based about
transgender ideology the inverse is true
and thus you create an encyclopedia that
contradicts itself
that's that's the very the easiest way
to point out uh in my opinion
and i only i only use the the the issue
of transgender ideology simply because
it is prominent in today's news space
and there is a hot political
conflict over this and again i
understand a lot of people say there
shouldn't be that's not the point the
point is
if you want to call conservatives
transphobes well then you've got trans
folks who are editing wikipedia
in in uh contradicting the posts by
these individuals
how can you have an encyclopedia that
tells you two different things or an ill
makes an illogical statement yeah well
that's because it's it's collaborative
basically it's made by um
as you say different groups of people
you you explained it beautifully i i
think that's absolutely right
well so then the issue becomes when you
look at someone like project verita when
you look at someone like james o'keefe
and project veritas
wikipedia is allowing unreliable sources
and conjecture to be used as
encyclopedic fact
right right well they bless certain
sources
as you know uh pre-approved that i mean
they they
include all kinds of stuff and that is
uh by
any objective measure pretty far left
um and and they banned all sorts of
stuff that is
merely on the right and not even very
far right
um and it's
yeah basically they they have selected
the sources
let's put it this way i i wrote an
article
um for my blog and it's been cited a lot
in the last few months
i think it's called um wikipedia
is biased or something like that i can't
remember enough
yeah um and it's it's really
uh uh it's very clear that wikipedia
takes sides in the culture war now
didn't used to
um but any topic that you can think of
that is important to
the cultural war you know from
you know topics like abortion
to subjects like religion figures like
hillary clinton or ronald reagan and to
um you know philosophies and
everything else um anything that has
a a connection uh to the culture war
wikipedia now um takes the left side
of the dispute and that i don't even
five years ago it wasn't so clear
it was biased five years ago but at
least they they
allowed the other side a say
right um even if it was if it was
biased and 15 years ago it was
still running off the original steam
of of real neutrality and you
actually it was it was striking back
then
to me compared to compare wikipedia
to things like cnn or for that matter
fox news of the time
you know where they you could go there
and you could really learn
in depth about different competing sides
of
all these different issues that is no
longer the case if you go
and and you look at about the issue
one of the issues that i that i found
was um
the adoption of
of um
adoption and generally by gay couples
that's an issue that that is somewhat
controversial
um there are different points of view on
that
and uh there you wouldn't know that
from the wikipedia article you mentioned
uh the black box of wikipedia and the
power players that
kind of run if not you didn't say run
the site i don't want to put words in
your mouth there but
it sounded like they're making the
decisions and they're you say they're
not people that work for the company but
who are they that's a good question
um i i don't know
um some of them work for pr firms
right uh and and and companies that
specialize in the uh
uh management
of reputation via wikipedia okay
i think there's got to be a fair number
of people who work for spy agencies
not just like the cia and fbi but all
around the world
probably you know um doing battle with
each other to make sure that that
that the articles are are
reading the right way i think there's
just a lot of corporate shills there
must be again
there has to be it would be they would
be irresponsible
frankly given the nature of the system
not to
you know spend some money and and uh
just
make the the truth as represented by
wikipedia
um reflect what they want it to be
and you said that you thought a solution
might be to get people to have their
real ids
in order to be able to be an editor on
wikipedia
well i um i'm
that's not a proposal that i'm making
about wikipedia i think it's a good idea
it's never going to happen but at the
very least what they could do
and this is more conceivable only
under great public pressure will they
even do this much
they need to at least identify by
real names and identities the
people who are making the important
editorial decisions
for wikipedia so the administrators
the check users and the bureaucrats as
they
are called in the system can you
describe what the check users are really
quick
the check users um if i remember right
are
the people who have the ability to look
up the ip address
associated with any account if you just
go there and you make an edit and you're
not logged in which is still possible on
wikipedia
then your edit will be credited to an ip
address everybody can see that
but if you simply make an account then
you can have your ip address
hidden from people except for the check
users and
and people who are above them thank you
it just seems like the uh
the people in power
they're biased they're they're they're
they're part of the cult they're part of
the
uh the tri uh the leftist tribe and
you you talk about changes that need to
happen but i just don't see that being
possible
yeah i don't i don't see at any point
the new york times shifting back to
reality because the people who control
the new york times
are either deferential to or part of the
cult
yeah i'm not really quite sure what you
mean by by cult
but um i'm just being offensive i'm
poking them on purpose i'm talking about
the the ultra woke tribal leftist
establishment types
right right right they're definitely
part of the establishment now
i mean and i basically mean
establishment the very idea
would have been absurd to us back in
2001 2002
that i mean wikipedia was part of
a counterculture um partly because
we were willing to represent all
different points of view
partly because we were not beholden to
any sort of corporate interests and so
forth
but and and even now wikipedia
um even though it gets big donations
from google so it kind of looks like the
wikimedia foundation
is is beholden to google and maybe some
others with deep pockets
nevertheless they they say they're not
responsible for the editorial decisions
um and i think that's true probably that
the wikimedia foundation
people there are not really responsible
for for the vast majority of editorial
decisions
on on wikipedia so it doesn't really
matter
necessarily that they're that they're
giving money
uh to the wikimedia foundation it
doesn't matter
those people still have ways of getting
money to the people who are making the
decisions
on wikipedia and not only do we have
some evidence that
of that you know individuals coming
saying that and pr firms saying well
yeah that's what we do
but it's obvious right i mean why
wouldn't
they this is how that's what pr is right
you use
all available um avenues
that affect uh your
clients reputation
that's what it's about wikipedia is
hugely influential so of course it's
happening why wouldn't it so wikimedia
is outsourcing the the burden of
editorialization it's kind of like when
the government outsources their
technology programs to private
corporations they can't get foia
requests because they're they're not the
ones working on it
so we can't sue wikimedia because
they're not the ones that are doing this
maybe getting paid or bribed by alphabet
or google well that's that's that's
certainly um what their defense
would be yeah and you actually would
have to
have their cooperation at least if you
wanted to
sue the people who are responsible for
definite defamation using wikipedia and
they don't want to cooperate with that
at all
right now uh wikipedia is known as a
platform and not a publisher is that
right
there's no legal distinction anyway so
like they're irrelevant
well for the sake of suing them uh under
section 230
now that's actually irrelevant bypassing
well if they were a publisher wouldn't
then you no that makes no distinction
really
yeah the issue is whether or not the
speech came from wikipedia or from its
users
it doesn't matter if you're a platform
or a publisher you could be a plumbing
company
and if you have a comment section on
your website and someone comments it's
something defamatory
you can't but if the if they edit the
their user's
comments and they're overseeing and
making sure they're allowed then aren't
they then if it wasn't
if it was an employee of wikipedia that
made a statement then you could sue
wikipedia
but what if there's an employee that
oversaw a statement and said that's okay
to be on our website
nope i don't think you're actually
disagreeing here i i think that
that uh just what it means to say that
they have
uh section 230 immunity is just to say
that the
the um the editing activity that's going
on is not being
done by the foundation it's being done
by the users and therefore the
foundation can't be sued
um for the for the
in the instance of james o'keefe suing
twitter twitter publicly stated james
o'keefe did
x they're claiming that james was
running multiple accounts
because they said that james can sue
twitter
what someone tweets you can't susan one
four so a blue checkmark
checkmark journalist can lie about james
o'keefe and he can't sue twitter for it
wikipedia is the exact same it's the
users who write
the pages not wikipedia
however i think you still need to start
suing
and i think the issue is the only way
you actually can get through
these suits is with case law uh times v
sullivan which set the standard was a
lawsuit which set the standard
so the only way to break through is to
start suing until
you find you you have the appropriate
argument you argue
wikipedia is a publishing platform
where they make statements of fact as an
encyclopedia they call themselves an
encyclopedia
which means users are to infer that
wikipedia is a place where facts are
being discussed
if a user posts something and is agreed
upon by a plethora of users
then i would argue that wikipedia must
either include this is the opinion of
our users in
every page otherwise wikipedia is
asserting it's a fact
so my argument would be by putting the
free encyclopedia on every page here we
have andy no
the encyclopedia makes the average
person believe they are reading facts
it does not say on this page this page
was written by a group of users who do
not work for wikipedia
how is the average person supposed to
know the inner workings of wikipedia
so you have to you have to think about
the intricacies of of of big tech
infrastructure
most people know that when a tweet
appears and it says ian crossland it's a
picture of you
and then it's and then it says something
like you know uh uh i made
uh a new loaf of bread with honey today
that statement came from ian crossland
because ian's name is on it
but forward-facing wikipedia pages do
not say that
you have to view the history in a
different page the page that is produced
i would argue
is actually published a statement from
wikipedia and not a statement from its
users
because the statements from its users
are visible only in a different page
called the view history page
if a bunch of users come together and
and imagine it this way
if a bunch of people tweet things uh
let's say i tweet ian crossland made
kombucha
lydia tweets ian crossland made bread
and then twitter
posts with the twitter logo ian
crossland made bread and kombucha that
is a statement
from twitter not from us and it's up to
them to verify
whether or not your opinions well
they're still
they're still they're still the actual
malice standard where twitter could then
argue
that we believe this to be true based on
the statements of ian's friends
which a judge would probably find fair
and many states have what's called
anti-slap legislation which would knock
this out
immediately making it very difficult to
sue the issue is
you need to sue until until you win
yeah i i you make it uh really
you state that argument very well and
and
um i want to see it tested in uh
in court i i i would just make more
i because i'm not a lawyer not going to
try to
pretend to be able to mount legal cases
or anything but
i am a philosopher so i'm going to talk
about the philosophical aspects of it
um the uh the current
legal situation in
in which there is no legal recourse
in the uh under the current like case
law
and the current statutory framework that
is supposed to govern wikipedia
it it makes it possible for people to be
grossly defamed by wikipedia and there
is no recourse for that
as an incredibly unjust situation
um it just introduces
all sorts of evil into the world that
should not be permitted
in a uh in a civilized society
um it's so basically
um there has to be
some way to force
a uh a legal recourse
and i don't know precisely what it is
maybe it's changing the law
but i think there's got to be a a a
judge out there who's going to say
look um john siegenthaler a senior
or whoever cheryl atkinson is another
good example i've talked to her a lot
about her
problems with with uh wikipedia
and a lot of other people um
all of these people um need some way
to be able to correct wikipedia
they need to be able to set the record
straight
because there is a record it's it's
taken to be
factual just as you say that's
absolutely right
well if it said every citation showed
the user who said it
then i would say that's a user's comment
but if a user makes a comment and then
wikipedia
puts it all into a page i i don't see
that as your comments i see that i see
that as wikipedia
making a statement here's here's another
part of an argument perhaps and this
this is
moral perhaps legal argument that
this wasn't the case back in 2001 but it
is now wikipedia has a reputation
it's a very important reputation because
if something appears on wikipedia a lot
of people just
assume that it's factual right um
and well what are people supposed to do
when uh lies really damaging lies
occur in that sort of situation
well um they could try suing
the wikimedia foundation but
the wikimedia foundation is going to
cite section 230
they can try to sue the uh
the user but how are they going to find
out who the user is if the user is
anonymous
so they could sue there could be a class
action lawsuit against the wikimedia
foundation
to the following um by all these people
who are
harmed by the wiki wikipedia system
which basically allows all of these
anonymous people
to to say damaging things
that have no recourse that's
itself a damaging situation for all of
those people it's a it's a
perfect class action lawsuit because
it's a whole class
that is affected by the um
the the situation do you think it would
force wikipedia wikimedia to shut down
if they were sued like that probably not
i mean
something had happened i hope i know
they ask for donations every year
they it seems like they're bootstrapped
i don't know if they're actually getting
funded by google
they probably got enough money but you
still got a phone they've got a lot of
money
and they've got a huge endowment and
they're not
hurting for money in any way shape or
form i
had uh some smear pieces written about
me i mean it happens periodically but i
don't get it nearly as much as some
other people which is really fascinating
to me
so i you know i pulled up andy knows
wikipedia
and boy is it in depth like these people
write about everything the guy does
my wikipedia is like kind of baron and
they're like why won't anybody write
about this guy i guess no one really
cares
but when i when i had articles written
about me that smeared me i remember i
called a lawyer
i called some friends some people with
legal experience and i was told
this news article first if an academic
writes an opinion piece and then a news
outlet says a new study
says tim poole does x you can't sue the
news outlet they're referencing a study
now the study will claim that they just
analyzed information and are giving an
expert opinion you can't sue them either
so okay so what do you do when an
academic who's an ideologue for the
for what are they called the humanities
asserts something to be a scientific
fact when it's just their
absurd opinion nothing well when
a news outlet actually smeared me
definitively as the writer
i talked with a lawyer and they said you
can't sue and i said why
and they were like the things they're
saying about you are opinions and i was
like but this is a
news article they're saying tim poole
did this
and they're like yeah but that's an
opinion and i was like
i don't i i'm i'm i'm i'm flabbergasted
by this
new lawyer no no i've talked to many
lawyers and they are correct so i
i talked to lawyers for 10 years about
copyright infringement manipulation lies
and smears
and i i i'm not going to pretend to be
as as well versed as a lawyer
but i've been through this many times
the problem was when
some if they if they were in an article
that says ian crossland is a white
supremacist
neo-nazi who who associates with
neo-nazis
those are all opinions you can't sue
them
well james o'keefe sued because the new
york times said
they were deceptively editing or
something to that effect
and this is when we got new new
precedent or at least
something you could you could reference
so far when the judge said
if you are writing a fact-based news
article or an article that's purporting
to be fact
stands to reason if you have if your
employees are injecting
or interjecting their opinions you must
inform your readers of that
this is what brings me to the argument
i'm making about wikipedia
same exact argument made by that judge
if wikipedia
is asserting two things that their
articles are
cited with reliable sources and the
articles are not opinion pieces
this is an encyclopedia right it's like
encyclopedia means fact
it's the facts about the issue but
they're not showing the user posts nor
are they putting this article was
authored by and a list of every single
person who wrote it
then wikipedia itself is making this
statement
so it's a very similar argument i'm
looking at this is what's changing the
game
and it's only possible because project
veritas decided to sue
even though many lawyers probably said
you can't win
they said we're gonna sue anyway i've
talked to way too many lawyers
i've talked to james about this on the
show we've talked about this and it's
very difficult
james o'keefe up on his website check
this out over at projectveritas.com
they have a donation page donate to
support our lawsuit against the new york
times they're trying to raise one
million dollars and you know what i'm
willing to bet it's gonna cost
them more than a million dollars to sue
the new york times so when
you're a small youtuber or twitter
personality
or maybe got a hundred thousand
followers and then a news outlet
that has a 24 year old far left
extremist who writes articles for them
writes mangled garbage saying ian
crossland is a white supremacist
how are you supposed to have a million
dollars to sue a major news
organization that 20 22 to 24 year old
psychopath
has the powerful institution at their
back and they can say whatever they want
you can't so this is why we talked about
this with james of the people's
defamation defense fund we're entering a
terror we're entering territory where
everyone is a public figure a kid
standing on the stairs lincoln memorial
was what they tried arguing was an
involuntary public figure you got a
twitter account they'll argue he's a
public figure she's a public figure
therefore the actual malice standard
applies
how is somebody who's just like a social
medias are supposed to compete with the
new york times
is a scary thing project veritas
got past a motion to dismiss and they're
they're well funded
you know i think they're a multi-million
dollar operation you can look at their
their 990s their their tax forms because
they're a 51c3
and they have good money but they don't
they don't make nearly as much as the
new york times does the new york times
is bringing in what like 50 million a
month or some ridiculous number from
subscriptions
the new york times can just say okay
everybody halt this month we're going to
dump 50 million to nuke james o'keefe
and what do you do it's called law fair
so james has gotten pretty far
and it's it's amazing this guy you know
the right conservatives moderates the
anti-anti-establishment we're going to
call this faction
has very few active personalities has
very few individuals willing to go to
war
the left every single person on the left
for the most part is willing to go nuts
they even throw bricks through windows
and risk
jail time but people on the right don't
do that it makes me think of david and
goliath this whole
this whole story that goliath is the
large unstoppable
warrior guy and david's this little guy
that has no chance in the eyes of the
masses of winning but
because he he actually has a chance he
knows he has a chance
and he has precision strike he's able to
throw a rock into the eye
of goliath and then blind him and then
take him down
but he really had the ability to do it
if you have no ability
don't try you're going to get killed but
james has
has righteousness on his side i believe
these people are doing the wrong thing
new york times
well it seems like they are defaming but
but it seems like they are
right right you you are correct but you
have to recognize david still needed the
rock and the sling yes
so there's a lot of people with
righteousness on their side or a better
word a better way to phrase it is
the truth on their side but do they have
the sling and the rock which is the
money the fundraising exactly
to be able to pay the lawyers and if
you're a random beggar on the street
seeking to defeat goliath and people are
like i don't know you and you're walking
around begging
you're not going to get the resources
you need well i like this people's
defamation
pdf pdf what
like basically uh an open community fund
that will help people sue for defamation
against these larger
i think wikipedia needs to be sued uh
you know
i'll let me let me tell you something i
remember when um
cassandra fairbanks sued over being
defamed because someone claimed that she
flashed a white power hand gesture
when she was just making the okay sign
it's not it's not but sure whatever the
media just kept saying it was because
4chan said it wasn't congratulations now
it is
i i wonder when i see a lot of these
lawsuits i'm very curious like why the
arguments tend to be so weak
and you know typically i just assume i
must not know enough about the law
you know it's a frame of popul a proper
legal argument
but then invariably these lawsuits fail
and i'm like
these judges are people they're not
morons
have you tried explaining to them in
basic terms instead of just making these
ridiculous arguments
why not just say like take a look at
your honor what do you think and then
you might lose i guess there's probably
there's good lawyers and there's bad
lawyers i suppose one way to put it but
i'm wondering
why is it that i'm sitting here and i
can see what wikipedia is doing
and i can i i can i can break down for
you exactly what i see
is wrong with this and it's what i said
when you go to twitter
and you'll retweet something we know it
came from you
but wikipedia is an encyclopedia and it
doesn't list its users
in the article even if you go to the new
york times the new york times puts a
byline
so you know who wrote it am i so i'll be
honest
i can't tell you who wrote anything on
my wikipedia page you know why
i'd have to go through three or four
hundred pages to look at every single
individual
to figure out what user this actually
came from even then you're only going to
get ip addresses
some of them yes so it's not even an
issue of coming from users
it's just random garbage splashed into a
background that wikipedia then publishes
it under its own name
nowhere on wikipedia does it say this is
user genera does it does it say in the
article
this article is written by an amalgam of
users here are the users here's how many
there are
they're going to need to buy
wikopinion.com it is wic opinion
it basically is that's all it is it's
wick opinion i'm sure they
own that but um you know so
to summarize your point in the point
that i was
making then um wikipedia has
this this um
total how do you you put it
um it has its reputation
it's asserting putting its reputation
behind the claims the factual claims
that are in the articles
that's on the one hand now on the other
hand they
are not taking responsibility
for the anonymous contributions and yet
it is precisely
the system of anonymous contributions
that um that they're putting their
reputation behind so their
responsibility they're responsible for
the anonymity
that they their their uh on principle
they're they're responsible for the
anonymity and therefore
insofar as that is the cause
of the the problem they
bear the uh the burden i wonder i wonder
i wonder i wonder
my my page on wikipedia is locked right
now meaning
users can't edit it without special
permissions
i mean that sounds like you have to you
have to have a certain number of edits
i believe that sounds like a job
criteria
what's the difference between the new
york times saying gift of approval from
the editor or
wikipedia saying you have to have
approval from our editors
yeah well i mean they've got they've got
standards but the standards
are supposed to be enforced only by
the volunteers so it's a volunteer
community that's what they're going to
say
if jane doe writes an article for the
new york times
saying ian crossland punched a dog
oh gee i'm coming and it's a false
statement of fact
you could sue the crazy thing is even in
that case there's still
actual malice and anti-slap legislation
but the idea is
you could sue the new york times james
o'keefe sued the new york times because
i think
two reporters made statements about him
the new york times as an organization is
responsible for publishing the speech of
these individuals
why they're just users on a website why
is the new york times responsible for
liab able to be sued over what users
wrote
because they're in the pay because
they're employees yeah
that means i should be able to uh
publish articles on timcast.com as
statements of fact and say whatever i
want about
about anybody and i can't be sued for it
if wikipedia can do it why can't i
yeah wikipedia has a has it has its uh
it's it's massive wikipedia the free
encyclopedia
and then it has all of these statements
that are written by who
i have no idea yeah i don't think it
should just be because they're paid
employees of the new york times and
that's why new york times is liable i
think because like a social network that
has unpaid users if the social network
masks that and just post the users
comments as
like minds if mine supposed to do that
and this is mine's
statement so we could we can oh that
would also be equally suitable i would
think so so this should mean that i can
open up
members of timcast.com to submit
articles
that i choose which will appear and just
say i didn't write it it was a user on
my website who submitted it
i just chose to have it published under
my brand name like wikipedia does
and you can click the source and see
only in the back end
a list of different people who
contributed to it and i ph
only an ip address we have no idea who
wrote jcip sue me what are they going to
do
you know maybe that's what i should do
maybe i should clone the wikipedia model
because what will happen is if someone
sues and wins i'll go oh no
then i'll turn around and see wikipedia
that's like for everything if you're
if they're committing war atrocities
against your people and you start
committing war atrocities against theirs
it's not necessarily the best
tactic i see your point i'm not saying i
prove a point like look how horrible
this is no i'm saying we can write
we can write our opinions about people i
can
look if wikipedia is issuing opinion
pieces
and asserting their fact then why can't
i
i think you legally can right now i
would i would you know what i'll do
i'll have users write articles and i'll
call it
the encyclopedia from timcast.com and
then i'll define
encyclopedia and then people can write
whatever they want at least make a movie
about it like a short five-minute
ridiculous dystopian nightmare wherever
and then i'll just i'll just say section
230 you can't sue me
over what my users said and they'll say
yeah but you're the one who's choosing
what's get published i'm like so is
wikipedia
twitter twitter bans people they choose
what's acceptable on their site
i am simply moderating for hate speech
all right yeah i just got to make sure
we don't get hate speech
actually the wikimedia foundation is is
doing that to a certain extent they've
they've actually uh announced a few
months ago that they're
adopting uh new policies um along those
lines
um so that's uh
that's interesting hate speech we should
start talking about
solutions now that i mean yeah uh legal
solutions so you
you were at wikipedia up until when did
you leave i i i was just there at the
beginning
2001 in 2002 um
at the beginning of 2002 i was there for
the first 14 months
um or you could say uh the first
a little over two years if you include
the the nupedia part
the new pedia part is important because
wikipedia couldn't have taken off
as fast as it did if new pedia weren't
behind it
but when you left did you had you seen
something going awry
at the company is that why you left or
did you just have well sort of
i i made a an ultimatum to
to jimmy wales first i i left because
they stopped paying me
um because they did their source of
funding
um i was the last of the new hires to be
to be laid off okay fine and i needed to
to
um spend my time actually making money
um
but then i permanently distanced myself
from the wikipedia uh project
uh at the end of 2002 the beginning of
2003
and i made jimmy wales an ultimatum i
basically said you need to do something
about the problem users that are
driving away all the good people um and
you need to give
some way uh
some sort of role even if it's
very almost nominal um
that that academics experts can have in
the system
maybe um approving on a different
website
official versions of site of uh articles
um and he he
basically rejected both out of hand it's
like i don't see the problem that you're
seeing is what he told me i could see
like a switch that you would flip in the
upper left if you wanted to create an
overlay that was like the academic
overlay of this of any given wikipedia
page or something like that so
that sounds off the website it's
actually what citizen citizendium does
oh so what is citizendium
so citizendium um and and
like i stopped working on it over 10
years ago now um
so and i'm not i'm no longer uh even the
owner i gave
ownership of that to to someone else and
and i'm sure she'll be announcing it
when
when uh the time is right um
but uh the the principles
um the following principles are still
true
um there's still a commitment to
um being more cordial toward
good writing to actually having a
coherent narrative that
that that pulls the article into a
single coherent whole
um and um the other thing is
that there needs to be real names
so there has to be real world
consequences for making a claim so
and and the third thing um or is it
fourth
there's um you have to agree
to a sort of statement of principles
when you're give
when you're given an account so it's not
hard to get an account
on and actually you can make an account
for yourself but
but it it becomes sort of official um
after your uh somebody reviews the
account
this was like a project that you started
after you left wikipedia
uh yeah well in 2006 and it really got
a big start in 2007 there was like
front page news and all kinds of
newspapers there was a big
ap feature story with a sidebar and and
there's a lot of reporting about it
and then it kind of petered out after a
year or two
mostly because wikipedia had its
greatest
growth curve at the time um and uh
so i i wish the citizenium uh all the
best
um but it's uh
the system is too similar to wikipedia
frankly people who want to work
in on that sort of thing
tend to go to wikipedia i think actually
when when they do a sort of relaunch
of the website and i don't know when
that's going to happen
um perhaps this year um
there's going to be a lot of renewed
interest in
in citizenium so there's a there's
another
alternative to wikipedia that has been
around for a while
it's called conservapedia have you ever
seen it oh yeah have you ever seen it no
so uh first let me just pull up regular
or conservapedia
and it says the trustworthy encyclopedia
sure
and if you go to conservativepd.com you
can see
uh featured on conservapedia over 800
million page views 1.5 million edits
you've got popular articles like second
amendment satan gun control chess
bible george patton all right well let's
let's jump over to uh
equal rights amendment that was one of
the featured articles
what does conservative pedia say about
it it was a proposed amendment to the
u.s constitution passed in congress 1972
sent to the states red vacation okay
blah blah blah we get the point it's got
numerous citations very similar to
wikipedia
all right this is a us.gov citation
it seems it seems this article is pretty
good on conservapedia well
let's let's see what it says about joe
biden
joseph robinette joe biden jr is the
current occupant of the white house
his right-hand henchman chief of staff
ron clayne has tweeted that 60 percent
of americans
are correct and they're i i don't even
read this stuff
and it's got a picture of joe who looks
freaked out and uh
yeah it's uh i'll tell you this
conservapedia is more biased than
wikipedia is and wikipedia is pretty bad
i think wikipedia is definitely giving
them a run for their money i mean it's
almost a parody
of itself now um there is a
another even more insanely
left source
out there uh called rational wiki and
they're just the worst of the worst of
the wikipedia conspiracy site
um well of leftist right uh flavor
yes well look it's because conservatives
don't do anything
sorry that's just that's just the
reality they're sitting at they're
sitting in their houses
minding their own business they want to
be like that's what conservatism is
right i mean i i mean it's all about
like wanting to
to be left your own devices and
and to basically preserve the order
and you know like causing a lot of noise
is is uh interrupting the the order that
you want to exist
they're not preserving the order yeah
it's like if you're sitting in your
chair
no unfortunately so so right now what we
see is
wikipedia was dominated at the
institutional level by
left you know leftists tribalists they
they're all all about the tribe
nothing else media institutions same
thing corporations
digital marketing and conservatives have
just sat back and watched it happen
yeah so then uh i guess in the long term
you lose
that's right so can i talk about
my new project yeah absolutely so what's
the solution
so the the solution that i have been
advocating for for a few years
now and that i've finally been able to
start working on
is um well i now call it uh
the encyclosphere so the encyclosphere
is not a website it's not
an app it's not even
a particular kind of software um
it will be when it exists in all of its
glory
um it will do for encyclopedias what the
blogosphere does for blogs it's going to
be a network
of encyclopedias so what ought to exist
is uh the ability to find
the latest and greatest articles from
any source that isn't articles that are
encyclopedia articles
to surface the best very quickly even if
they
were just written a couple of days ago
they should be able to
leap frog over the lame stuff that's on
on wikipedia that appears there only
because
google happens to to push it at people
because it's on on google are you
familiar with cytogenesis
sure yeah are you afraid of this oh yeah
so this is a i believe it was a xkcd
comic that coined the phrase
so what happens is someone will randomly
edit uh correctly if i'm wrong someone
randomly adds wikipedia pages like a fit
with fake information
yeah and then a writer at levitton post
will be like i need to write about
larry sanger so they pulled the wiki and
it says he once
you know he was a a a an air force pilot
in world war ii yeah
and then they go they go they go to
their right their article and say larry
sanger an air force pilot from world war
ii is also a co-founder of wikipedia
publish then someone wikipedia says hey
whoa whoa what is this
what is this they're claiming this guy
was an air force pilot in world war ii
he's not that old
and then someone will go ah it's right
here from huffington post and then they
add the source
and now it gets cited in wikipedia and
cytogenesis references that wikipedia
fake information is used by journalists
and then becomes the source for itself
it's so gross like eating your own poop
so how do you solve for that
in in your you know solution well you
you mentioned jumping over wikipedia for
instance so i'm like how do you get past
things like that
okay well that's that's an issue about
quality um
and what i what i propose
um is if we're already
defining uh technical standards for the
publishing of
encyclopedia articles in the same way
that that
rss and adam are technical standards for
defining the publishing of blog posts
right um so if we're already doing that
then we ought to be able to add to those
standards um
some standards
for evaluating articles for allowing
people to
post their ratings of articles
so a sort of decentralized centerless
leaderless
system for um allowing people to declare
what their rating of various of the
various contents of the encyclosphere
is and and by the way the cyclosphere is
not like a new encyclopedia it's not an
encyclopedia it's a collection of all
the existing encyclopedias or it will be
plus any new stuff that is added
i have a solution yeah okay why don't i
just like
buy some funkin wagnalls or britannica
those still exist right
sure no but what about the paid
encyclopedias i mean
those could be an easy path or are those
institutions biased as well
uh well uh a little bit not nearly as
bad as wikipedia but what data it
doesn't that doesn't solve
the the problem um they're relatively
small
and um people go to wikipedia the reason
that wikipedia took off in the first
place is that it's got all kinds of
information
that can't be found in other sources and
unfortunately that's still
the case i it's fortunate that it exists
right so don't get me wrong about that
i've never
denied that wikipedia is very useful it
is
um but it's unfortunate that
that's the only easily findable source
of information
but if there were simply a way to get
the information easily in front of
people from many different sources
as if it were all in one source
then well i think people would actually
use that rather than
than wikipedia it's kind of like what
we're working on with the fetaverse
are you familiar with the fetiverse yeah
well it decentralizes encyclopedias
um so uh that the fetiverse
decentralizes
uh social media i'm wondering when you
do
ratings on uh encyclopedia articles so
if you want a grand user rating system
so you want to put the best stuff to the
top
if you get one article with a hundred
ratings
98 of them are four or five stars two of
them are one star
but then you look at that user they put
the one star and look across their
their scope of ratings and see if
they've often given ratings that are
counter to the mass
and then downgrade their value as a
radar yeah
well you're thinking about this from the
point of view of an app developer which
is fine
um but that's if you really want a
decentralized system you can't think in
those terms what you want to do
is simply uh create these
the um the technical infrastructure the
architecture as it's called
um for for getting the ratings out there
and associating them with with an
identity a real
uh trustworthy identity so i if
if a rating of an article about
epistemology say
um claims to be from me somebody can
prove that it is actually from me
so you need to solve this sort of sorts
of technical problems
and then once the data is out there
just like once all of the blogs are out
there or once all of the encyclopedias
are out there
using the same standard then there can
be a zillion different apps
that are built on top of that and you
don't have to agree
on whose ratings are are worth um
you know uh following and using and all
the rest of that
you know there can be a bunch of
different algorithms
for deciding what the the most uh
reliable article is
what if the solution is uh actually kind
of simple
remake wikipedia but require real
identities
for everyone that's what citizen dm did
oh really
yeah there's also peer identity which is
interesting because rather than me
having to give you my driver's license
and my identification so i'm
centralizing some database somewhere
if i get enough people another peers to
acknowledge that this
is me they see i like dogs i like cocker
spaniels i love the number four i'm a
big
fan of the color green just so you all
know and then they can be like yeah
that's ian and then so all these peers
across the network also anonymous
can verify that they think that's me and
then you go to each of these people and
they seem legit because other people
have verified that they think that's
them
you have a system of you know value i
don't think that change is just
requiring someone to use their name it
enables anonymous
uh anonymous personalities oh right but
you still have you
you have a verified identity but not
your your real identity yes
yeah it let's let's put it this way um
whatever the identity system looks like
i just want to make sure that it's not
actually owned by the us government
or by google or apple um
or the un uh or any other
sort of giant um
organization that is not responsible to
the people it really needs to be
a standard a specification a technical
standard
um that just gets the information out
there and then allows people to
you know to come up with their own uh
systems of of in this case identity
i agree the problem is my identity is
based on the
the us government has given me my
identity gave me my social security
number
that's one sort of name on my birth
certificate so like i am a product of
this
government right now that's just an
identity
yeah that's just a datum though all
right we want a system of identity that
is truly
independent of that basically if if you
allow the government to
own your digital identity and this is
that's what
that's what it's called digital identity
it's super important
it's going to be one of the hottest most
important
issues in um basically internet politics
of the next several years
if it's owned by the government or if
it's owned by google or whatever
then they in a certain way they own you
like there's all kinds of things you
won't be able to do if they decide to
shut you off
so you have to be able to own your own
not just your own data
but also your own identity and and
right now there's there's fighting going
on it's very low key
it's very polite but it's real
fighting going on at the w3c i know one
of the people who
is doing the fighting actually um
between corporate interests who
want a system that can be controlled
where you don't in fact own your own
identity that
corporate interests do versus
a system where you can own your own
identity and you can you can lay claim
to
anonymous identities that doesn't force
other people to
to accept them i want to bring up this
story real quick
uh this is from the daily mail pfizer
ceo says a third covid vaccine dose will
be needed
as soon as six months after someone
receives two
shots and then people will be vaccinated
annually
the reason i bring this up is first they
said you know it's two shots
they say it's three first had one mask
then two fine whatever
my point is not necessarily the amount
of shots you have to get i guess once a
year
the issue is the vaccine passports and
the private requirements
for you to carry around some form of
digital identity that will allow you
access
and carry around your private records if
they're coming out now saying well you
need three
what happens if you get your vaccine and
you're like great back to normal
now you have your vaccine passport we've
normalized this then the ceo of a
massive private corporation comes out
and says actually
you need three well now all the other
private corporations the walmarts the
stores the the cruises the airlines are
going to be like
well the ceo pfizer said it so we have
to update our rules because they're the
experts
now you are forced to go back in this is
why we can't allow this kind of thing to
be normalized
but it brings to the i bring this up
because the larger point you're making
about a digital identity
owned by the government is
for one you're completely correct we
can't allow the ownership of our
identities
but i think it's going to be private
corporations that do this yeah there's
going to be
a consortium of sorts that says we
should have a standard like a blockchain
thing
and then you have your private key won't
everyone like this
yeah but then when he centralized
because it's on the blockchain
right now most blockchain projects are
not decentralized i'm here to tell you
folks
they're not really decentralized not in
the sense in which the dns system
and email and the blogosphere and usenet
if you remember that and many other
things the backbone of the internet
is decentralized blockchain ain't
decentralized in that way
this is why i think um bitcoin is
actually a really
great risk to freedoms and i've said
this for a long time
uh it'll be worth a lot of money because
i think there's powerful interests that
realize the power of bitcoin and being
able to track
everything you do it's beautiful the the
artificial intelligence
the fact that the blockchain is public
they can track you
if you are using bitcoin you have
started publishing your digital identity
to a certain degree
again bitcoin is very valuable i have i
have some it's been skyrocketing in
value i think for obvious reasons
it's useful for governments but i
remember going back and way back in the
day
when bitcoin was first gaining some
prominence and i had some anarchist left
friends some anarchist right friends
and it was really the the anarchists
left weren't really paying attention to
this stuff
the the libertarian and and cap people i
knew were like this is amazing we can
have a system of value to exchange the
government can't track it
and i was like dude this is the most
easily tracked thing
ever what are you talking about and
they're like no you're wrong
and i was like wow how is it that you
have
walked into one of the most easily
surveilled systems
and you don't realize it so what happens
when bitcoin becomes a standard
it's skyrocketing in value what happens
when a bitcoin which has eight eight
decimal points becomes worth the
equivalent of one million dollars
you now have a digital international
standard of
easily tracked currencies that people
will say it's decentralized
to a certain degree but if every massive
major multinational corporation requires
the use of bitcoin
well it's not really decentralized then
because this international consortium
can simply say
we all agree we will not accept bitcoin
from ian this address
banned and then any address associated
with it banned
right and because it's publicly
exchanged
you will have to there's ways to do it
but you'll have to then
essentially launder your coins to
another address
and then to a different address maybe
using monero or something
so that they can't publicly see your
coins or associated with a certain
address but what happens if they say
if we track any of these coins
going through any address they're no
good anymore
well then there's nothing you can do
those coins are essentially defunct
and they've excised you from society
it's hard to do with cash
with hard us dollars you got paper money
it's valuable you can hand it off to
somebody they don't know who had it or
when they had it i mean they can track
it to a certain degree
with bitcoin ian's money could could be
deemed
all of the money and this address is now
worthless and anybody who trades in it
will be banned from the network as well
and people back i'm not trading with you
ian
there's no way to get that money out
that's a beaut
beautiful system i'm i'm i've never uh
look i understand the technology i think
ethereum's brilliant brilliant
technology it's gonna
do a lot of really great things but
people don't realize
you know when uh the far right as they
as they say
started taking bitcoin news outlets
started publishing the amount of money
these people had
there you go yeah i don't think using
bitcoin as a store of value
is really the future i think it's the
smart contracts themselves and the
ability to transact a token
a digital piece of information that
activates a program what's ethereum
yeah ethereum right right that's
brilliant technology you can remove the
middleman of the dude sitting there
flipping the switch for you once he gets
his paycheck like
the there's is another one that's that's
what
uh that's what uh the
everpedia the blockchain encyclopedia
basically they forked wikipedia
they added another million articles a
lot of them are auto-generated but
they've written a lot
by hand for sure um about
all kinds of topics that aren't in
wikipedia they're like
not notable enough or something or
people who are only internet famous or
or whatever and
and it's cool and i i support them they
actually are
um uh built on eos
um unfortunately they're an example
and i don't want to say anything too
negative about even eos here
but it bothers me i'm i'm sorry i just
have to say it
that that the block producers at least
back in 2019 i don't know what the
current situation is
the people who are responsible for
deciding
what goes on the eos blockchain
they were all owned by chinese
corporations
so i mean okay it's decentralized in one
sense but it's kind of centralized in
another
really important sense too the issue is
private corporations of which there is
an ever decreasing amount that own
everything
the the ceo of disney can go to the ceo
of unilever and be like hey so we agree
like ian crossland's banned from society
right
and they'll make sure every company is
is off limits to you i truly believe we
need a program that will allow
every individual to spin up their own
token that then they can use as their
own value transactions so if you want to
subscribe to my channel you can give me
ten dollars a month or you can give me
nine dollars a month in ian coin
but why why why would they have to give
you ten percent so they get ten percent
off
listen this is what yeah this is what
how everpedia
solves the problem so i don't wanna be
come down too
hard on them but they have told me that
if
if eos starts if like the block
producers the chinese block producers of
eos start censoring the content
of everpedia then they'll just
make it possible to to um
transact edits essentially um
using a different coin and that that
would be cool
if we can trust them i just don't like
having to trust people
when when the whole system is supposed
to not require trust
that's the whole idea supposed to be
trustless
i suppose we can just talk about the
positives in a society
with your digital identity owned by
massive corporations crime will be gone
people will get arrested immediately
there'll be no more need for
investigations
passion murder will happen robberies
will happen but people will be
immediately apprehended and locked up in
a private prison
for uh you know for profit uh-huh sounds
right
here no more trials all hard evidence
everything's on the blockchain interact
and we will all live walking with forced
smiles
i don't like that everything is great
i'm happy are you happy ian you're happy
i want to talk about encyclosphere hey
sure okay no that that didn't make me
happy though
that was funny what's um how far along
are you within cyclosphere right now
um so well we've been
doing laying the groundwork basically um
a few different things so we've we've
raised some money
we've incorporated and we've applied
for 501c3 status we've got
uh three different software projects
going
um one is called
fact seek factseq.org it's just a
an encyclopedia meta search engine it's
it's not much but it's useful
for sure another one another
encyclopedia meta search engine
is um and these aren't owned by us
they're just affiliated with us
and the the people who are working on
those are people who
are are committed to helping to develop
the standards for for publishing
encyclopedias
um let's see uh the other one is called
encyclosearch.org
um and then uh we are also
directly paying for the development um
it's not encyclopedia related but
it's still decentralized uh i have a
plug-in
for wordpress that
um basically uh
it allows you to run your own
micro blog so like your own twitter feed
that you own
nobody can shut it down um via a
wordpress blog
so i'm already doing that on on
a website called startthis.org
but pretty soon that's going to be
running a different theme
and pretty soon after that there's going
to be a plug-in in addition to the theme
and in a later iteration it's actually
going to be possible
for different blogs to talk to each
other and it'll
look just it'll look and act something
like wikipedia does but it's all going
to be transacted
via um blogging uh standards the rss and
atom
standards so like when i pull up one of
your articles i'll be looking at like
the dog went to the zoo
and i'll be able to click on zoo and
it'll take me or like
mouse over the word zoo and it'll like
pull up like uh
um well no uh i was just now talking
about
about um decentralizing social media
using this
wordpress plugin if you're if you're
asking about the encyclosphere
the encyclosphere is um
so it's it's hard to explain and i
apologize a lot of people aren't going
to be able to get it
on on the first pass and it's because
it's it's com
complicated i'm not accusing anyone of
being dense there's all kinds of
brilliant people who need this to
explain several times
and that's not because i'm smart is
because it's got a lot of moving
parts right so the idea is we're
building a network of encyclopedias or
another way to put it is we're building
a way to network together
all of the existing encyclopedias and
then for just
ordinary people to add new content
very easily and quickly so imagine
a search engine that that
covers all of the existing encyclopedias
maybe it doesn't have all of the content
of the articles but at least it has the
metadata so it allows you to
find really quickly and easily the best
encyclopedia articles on each topic
that it might be something you would use
to find articles instead of
wikipedia if it were really good enough
okay what if
in addition to that you had the ability
through say another wordpress blog
plugin
to like just press a button after you've
written your own
one-off encyclopedia article and it's
added
to the same database then you wouldn't
have to ask permission
of anyone to uh to add to this and i
think there would be
all kinds of hobbyists and and um
and experts and professors and
researchers and
all all kinds of people who would be
delighted to have a an effective way of
adding to
the world's knowledge and it wouldn't
just like
be buried way down in the search results
of google
it would actually be in a format that
can be
collected and redistributed in a zillion
different ways
by a bunch of different independent apps
see so it's creating the technical
infrastructure
for people making lots of different
competing apps that tap into the same
body
of encyclopedia articles i would love
for like um
as i'm reading any boing boing article
or whatever that i can
mouse over and click on any word in the
article or just mouse over and it'll
show me an overlay if i want to pop this
you know in cyclosphere app or whatever
it is up browser extension
something like an extension sure as well
as watching a video and you see the
the closed captions i can choose any
word that comes up in the closed caption
and if i see a bird flying by in the
video
i could somehow search what like what is
that so that they have bypass languages
they have that already yeah stuff for
some time actually
um i think google built it where you
could be watching a video and then stop
or or they demoed this and the ai can
identify in an image what a
like google does this you can show an
image and i'm like this is a lamp this
is an
apple and so that was one of the ideas
you're watching a show
it could pause and you could be like
what's that shirt it would do instant
google image search and then
show you the product where to buy it
different idea
one's an encyclopedia one's a market but
uh you know
we should jump over to super chats
though and uh see what the audience has
to say
and uh i'm first going to state
something uh the other day
i get a message from my brother and he's
like hey buy dogecoin and i was like
whatever and so i just was like fine and
i bought some dogecoin i didn't even
think twice
i don't know i don't care i was like
sure whatever my ten-year-old son has
bought
aged coin it was at 10 cents it's at 25
cents right now
he's made money so i bought some
and i'm seeing the chat below where
people are like dogecoin full disclosure
i bought some
i am not confident i just didn't care
all that much
because it's a quarter so i like just
bought some and uh and that now it's
well we'll see could you imagine i
here's a i would i would love this
considering i just bought some dogecoin
i would love dogecoin just to beat
bitcoin and become
the actual but i guess doge has no real
support or something i don't know
anyway my friends smash that like button
if you'd like to support the show and
subscribe
we are going to take your super chats
the first super chat we have is
rj colu says tim if states texas seceded
would you move to those states yes
absolutely really a whole other country
a new country
texas yeah if it would it become its own
country is that the
what about what it got invaded actually
i got to be honest i'd say no i would
that's dangerous
if texas secedes i would wait a little
bit
and if texas stays true to its values
and the constitution and it upholds
rights and expands them because i guess
they're talking about constitutional
carry
i'd probably do it what would you do
there
uh i don't know i i i if that happened i
would
uh worry about the us
government stopping people from
emigrating
i mean because i think that would be a
real possibility
i'd think about that there'd be a lot
that would go into the
in the decision i i there's no way to
know
without all the facts um the whole
situation maybe a little bit for sure
maybe i i do want to mention i am not
giving financial advice
i i actually would say in my you know i
am not confident in the fact that i just
bought dogecoin but
i like it it's funny so i'm the doge the
doge i i didn't you didn't you buy some
yeah i bought a bunch
of them thousands back when they were
like nine cents it spiked to nine cents
i was like i gotta get in on this and
then it dropped down to four and i was
like
what have i done but i had diamond hands
that's right it's at twenty five so
twenty seven listen
i i didn't i didn't break my bank for
this i bought some dose because i
thought it was funny yeah it's
if if if doge goes up to bitcoin levels
i'd probably be like i should have
bought more dude
lex friedman and elon musk's funny is
the entire
proposal we have like some of the
preeminent
uh artificial intelligence geniuses of
the world lex friedman and elon
tweeting about it and loving it like
these are like the
top geniuses on earth so all right we
got we got a very important one from
jonathan galterini
jd llm larry sanger how does one
classify as an ex-founder
if you helped found the company how do
you unfound it i'm not intending to be
rude lol i'm honestly asking
it's tongue-in-cheek obviously um
it's like it's it's a reference to a
couple of different things
one is when people when i'm identified
as a co-founder
a lot of people have just assumed that
i'm still there and they like
criticize me for it and it's like i'm
tired of being criticized for
wikipedia when i'm like on the front
lines criticizing wikipedia myself
okay so that's part of it another part
is
jimmy wales back in like 2004 2005
started denying that i am co-founder
um really oh yeah that's a it's a big
story but it was back then i don't
really
care anymore but um but you know
he still hasn't come out and just said
yeah he's co-founder
um and uh so
it's like okay fine i i am gonna just
i'm just gonna like uh
distance myself from it entirely call
myself ex founder
jimmy now you are the co you are the
sole founder okay you're the sofa
so that's fine go ahead all right we got
matt daniel he says hey tim
i bought dogecoin after you talked about
it in january during the gamestop thing
it's gone from point zero zero three to
point one nine
i made bank dude
i mean you know what i
i should stop and think to myself about
what i'm doing because i often
look i remember when i was talking about
bitcoin was two dollars and now it's 20
and everyone thought that was it
and then i still don't buy anything so i
remember when in november bitcoin was at
13 000.
now it's at 63. geez wow ethereum was at
a thousand
i remember when ethereum was like what
five bucks yeah and i was like oh that's
a cool thing everyone's like this is
great stuff and i'm just like
i you know what i'm i'm i'm not giving
financial advice i'm trying to criticize
myself
for being so smart and stupid at the
same time smart enough to be like i can
see why that's valuable
but i'm not gonna buy it and now it's
like you know 10 years later and i'm
like why didn't i buy it what's wrong
with me so i'm just going to
buy dumb things i guess left is insane
are you planning on taking substances
like mdma lsd or dmt in the future yes
if not can you have someone on the show
who knows a lot about them and can
accurately describe the experiences
those are illegal by the way now
i suppose they're talking about in an
academic setting where they have the
legal
authority to do so in oregon no i
wouldn't however there is that extended
state dmt thing that we talk about
you know every so often which is really
interesting have you experimented much
with psychedelics
no it doesn't seem like that guy ian
they're amazing sometimes women
actually develop actually you gotta like
you just gotta look at larry and then
look at ian
and then it's like larry's definitely a
psychonaut
i found with lsd and i think you need to
look in a mirror lsd lets you see
shape like structure easier for me it
did anyway and i was able to more like
mathematically perceive the shapes
which helped for like development and
coding interesting
yeah all right we got uh dr roller gator
he says congratulations on one million
subs lydia great job as always thank you
thank you absolutely a real president
yeah dave says hey tim i was working at
a plastic extrusion plant in wisconsin
in wisco and the boxes we were putting
some rolls in said made in china on them
makes you wonder how often it happens to
other products that are actually made in
the usa oh yeah
i bought an air purifier and it says
designed in florida made in china
or like assembled in china i'm like i
get come on just
just admit it you made it in china
yep joseph cole says tim you've inspired
me to move out of the city
i am moving my family out of denver we
can't take the dems bs anymore thank you
for the push
that's i mean i don't know much about
denver i've been there a couple times
uh i was in colorado springs for fort
carson i believe right yeah
big mountains um but i yeah i got out of
the city because it's awful it's nice
and you you realize how awful it is when
you get out of the city i've i've uh
we've we've been out of the city since
2005. wow uh in the excerpts i i had a
friend hit me up
you know saying like you know i got the
vaccine i'm so excited normalcy
we're coming back and i'm just like
we've been in normalcy like out here
forever like i was talking to one of the
locals out here and they're like nothing
changed for us
literally nothing you're in the
mountains you're in the middle of
nowhere you wake up in the morning you
go outside there's chickens running
around pooping all over the place
in new york though you can't go outside
it's crazy man l.a was just a depressing
nightmare when i was there
people waiting in line outside of whole
foods that's really sad afraid of each
other
but you bought some dogecoin that made
you feel better i made a bunch of dosh
coins
got a bunch of those ian's secretly a
dogecoin millionaire i love it
don't wait don't hesitate oh don't give
advice
no no just in life don't hesitate okay
okay that's good that's good advice
daniel says hey guys i really enjoy what
you're doing here and i've been watching
you tim since 2018.
you've really inspired me with
everything that you've done and now i
have my own independently hosted website
webitology on google hey there you go
awesome whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
matthew alcazar says the texas state
house just passed constitutional carry
in an 84 to 56 vote they passed it we
are here holy cow
now that goes to the senate i suppose it
will go to the state senate if they have
a
senate and i imagine it's going to pass
it's texas of all places seriously west
virginia is constitutional carry
you don't need anything you can just go
to west virginia and walk around with a
gun you can put it in your
belt and you know it's normal in the
west
a lot of people don't don't realize this
like not california oh no no no not not
in california
or again oregon and washington are
pretty pretty good on guns
right that's my understanding i don't
know a lot not the east coast
yeah the progrado well colorado's
getting worse
oh yeah okay you're turning blue the
bros durham says wikipedia did a number
on count dankula and the quartering's
boss
interesting brendan leach said mr sanger
thank you for making research in high
school and college so much easier
in particular all of the links to the
actual articles yeah
that's what i always said it's like if
you've got a problem with the article
just click the link seriously
here's here's the funniest thing i love
about wikipedia uh i i
i proved a point to my friend this is
probably 15 or something years ago
that you could take a link to a long
complicated complicated scientific
journal
and then say whatever you want so long
as you put in the citations
so you could take a scientific journal
that says like you know the the the uh
the reality of you know sleeping babies
in
a construction zone or something and
then find an article about
sleep apnea and then say whatever you
want
can loud banging noises have been found
to be soothing for babies
and then put that citation next to it
people would click it see the journal
not read the journal and assume it was
true no
that's that's one of the wikipedia's
many dirty little secrets they have
very many and that's definitely one of
them that
that a lot of the uh citations don't
actually say what they're supposed to
say um or or they they have uh
um basically
added their own bias to what a less
biased source says
right yeah that's um it's i mean news
outlets do the exact same thing pathetic
yeah
absolutely framing tools brilliant so my
favorite my favorite you're going to
love this is uh we had the big story
about
russian bounties on american troops
turns out it's not true my favorite
thing is
instead of coming out and saying the
story's not true what they said was
well we had low to moderate confidence
that russian agents sought to encourage
the taliban
and i'm like hold on hold on
hold on if you said we had load of
moderate confidence that russian agents
encouraged the taliban i would assume
there was a small likelihood they
actually encouraged it
when you say you had low confidence they
sought to encourage them
you add that word and what the story
really is
they think russians at some point
considered talking to the taliban but
probably didn't
yes i'm soaking to be a trillionaire
right now
so no article is going to say that i'm a
trillionaire well no
it would be like saying uh uh breaking
news ian crossland
uh you know paid 1 trillion paid a
billion dollars
to build a helicopter in in his backyard
and then it's like later it's like well
actually the story may have not been
true
and then the quote you give is that you
sought to pay a billion dollars to build
a helicopter
yes i seek to find excalibur from the
lady in the lake and then become the
true king of the britons too tim
found excalibur that's right yes or it's
it's
quote me on it for now they're creating
they're creating another point removed
where the story is actually it's
probably some like russian guy who was
like
hey vladimir do you want to pay taliban
to kill americans
and then they're like nah okay and then
they're like write it down and publish
we have low ex low evidence what do they
say
low low to moderate confidence low
confidence that it may have happened
all right we got student of history who
says these people have tickled the
dragon's tail and now they will see the
wrath of veritas
if he is going after them i say go forth
and reap all you can he has taken their
dignity and professional honor
now he'll take the smear merchants
ill-gotten gains
it's going to cost a lot of money i mean
look veritas is seeking to raise a
million dollars to go up against the new
york times
they're gonna need to raise millions
more to go up against twitter and cnn
and
and brian stelter and anna cabrera's
individuals we'll see if they have it
all right let's see where we're at
jacob and m clutter says tim i think you
guys are looking at james not suing
wikipedia the wrong way
he's going after the new york times to
weaken or destroy section 230
if he succee if he succeeds that would
open wikipedia up to be sued
yeah this is interesting if if um this
will be interesting
there's a lot of dead citations as well
for instance uh
sure the news outlets change their
articles every day
minute after minute they'll publish an
article then update it an hour later
someone on wikipedia will take an
article that says you know ian crossland
did a backflip
put it up on wikipedians as a fact and
then an hour later
when this editor is long gone the
article changes to say correction it was
a front flip
now you've got a bad citation i wonder
if we'll be able to fix hyperlinks so
that in the future if the receiving end
of the hyperlink alters the hyperlink
disappears i think that was a
proposal in the original um
world wide web specification if i'm not
mistaken
um and and they decided against it
um because they wanted to keep the
system
maximally simple um if you start
trying to track stuff like that it just
becomes much
much too difficult um
so yeah actually i have the last little
tidbit directly from one of the
co-founders of
the world wide web who actually is uh
has has uh weighed in in the the
knowledge standards foundation
which is developing the and psychosphere
i'm i i'm
uh proud to say uh and humble humbled
uh to say but um yeah he basically
has said a lot of the decisions that
we made and a lot of the reason why html
is as sloppy
as it is is that uh we wanted it to be
simple
and flexible um and that was the right
decision to make basically it wouldn't
have
wouldn't have flourished the way it did
if it weren't kept that way is that
barlow
john barlow um no no i like that guy a
lot
someone someone mentioned in the
comments i don't want to name his name
because
because i didn't have his permission to
oh okay so
shout out to the dude we have a comment
it's a regular comment they said um
ian is a backflipping dog punching white
supremacist tim poole
quote it oh yeah because whenever i make
reference to fake news i'll be like
they'll say ian did this or ian did that
start my wikipedia and i won't take it
down oh yeah
so here's the funny thing too it would
not be
a lie if a news outlet said tim poole
accused ian of punching a dog
or or they would say tim poole said
quote ian punched a dog
because i did say those words context is
irrelevant to these people
then someone would take that and put in
wikipedia ian has been accused of
punching dogs
like that's the laundering of
information and flipping backs
you guys ever do a backflip flipping
backs i have done many backflips
actually
still go to a parkour gym every so often
it was fun it freaked me out backflips
yeah
i should do front flips are easier i
mean i guess actually backflips
are easier but scarier do you do
backflips or back walkovers
backflips oh that's something well i
mean i don't do them anymore
but there's actually a video on my
youtube channel that people won't be
able to find of me
doing a uh i jumped up onto a platform
and then front flip off of it
yeah i probably could still do front
flips i mean i still skate and
skateboard and stuff like that so
i've got a son who's trying to learn
boarding or parkour
what's that skateboarding oh no uh doing
front flips or doing flips yeah there
was a there was a parkour gym in
brooklyn
and i would go there and just bounce
around it was a lot of fun i was really
good at doing side talks that that for
some reason that seemed the easiest to
me
and i think it's because it's the least
scary like when you do a front flip
you're you're
you got to jump right your head's going
down you do a backflip you don't want
your head
when you do a side tuck your neck your
head is not exposed it's like you fall
you fall on your back
and it was really easy to learn because
what i would do is out
this is how they taught me i would just
roll over that this big foam obstacle
and you just jump and roll on your back
and then eventually they have you jump
more and then jump more and then they
take it away and then you're side
tucking
and flipping and then yeah the parkour
stuff was fun
it's good fun all right chris de luca
says i live in albuquerque new mexico
and 20 cops quit over the weekend
because of protests bravo i'm applauding
and i quote they do not feel supported
here and they don't feel trust they feel
second guessed
and they don't feel that they can do
their job no matter how perfect they do
their job without getting in trouble
i am going to look into that that is a
great story i would love to to to go and
end up on
all right let's see knuckles says
dogecoin to the moon 23 cents so that
was actually a little while ago i think
it's actually like 28 cents right now
people are snap how did how is dogecoin
skyrocketing like this
it's funny i'm going to buy it i'm not
telling anybody to do anything i'm going
to buy more
but only because it's funny it might be
at it might be peaking right now so you
might want to wait a day
too i'm just going in no don't care i
went into nine cents and i don't regret
it
i didn't go down but then it went back
up i want to be i'm not spending that
much money
like it's like it's like i'm throwing
you know tons of cash into this i bought
a little bit
it's funny i want to be able to say i
have dogecoin yes
did you buy doge i did i should have
bought it months ago when it was funny
still but you know there you go
all right jandyn patterson says got the
whole gorilla t-shirt collection even a
pink
diamond gorilla t-shirt for the wife got
two of the regular
plus two versions i am a
gorilla25membertimcast.com as well
thanks for telling the truth and
big thanks to miss lids oh thank you yep
we
um now we got somebody so much hiring to
do um we need a web dev
so somebody who lives in the dc area
email jobs at timcast.com this is a web
editor position we're looking for
somebody who can just maintain and knows
how to handle wordpress and probably css
it's css right that's what i'm saying
that is content system what does css
stand for
know how to do wordpress stuff and so uh
also post articles
there's a lot of people like that but
we're also looking for a master of
ceremonies
yes for the friday night events of which
we want to do
every friday with one big monthly event
where
our members actually have the option to
buy tickets and show up
in limited capacities probably like 20
or so people
that's an mc for tim cass media yeah
some
and the mc would actually be helping run
the vlog so the bigger the position is
coming up with ideas for fun things to
film and then friday night is the big
fun stuff cool job yeah bands playing
comedians all that good stuff
you know so jobs at timcast.com
and uh i don't know
resumes aren't as important as portfolio
material
cascading style system is that css i
don't know okay
send me pictures of websites send me
links to websites you've made
and send me videos about vlog stuff
you've done thank you there you go
we're also hiring uh we're going through
we're looking for a paranormal
subject matter editor so cults murders
mystery paranormal
we have a lot of ufo news coming out
right now so this would fall absolutely
into the purview of this this person
this writer the reason we're hiring for
this because this would also be the
production for the new show we're
putting together
which is a podcast on murder mystery
cult's paranormal we'll be doing that
with cassandra fairbanks it's gonna be a
lot of fun
yeah all right all right let's read some
more
set me free says good wins in the end
because it comes together to defeat evil
that's what's happening now with all
these different personalities echoing
information
be good examples in your communities the
left is coming together
they're collectivists they're a hive so
yeah
it's not ever until it's over that's
true noah poa says two plus two equals
seven right don't worry tim jerry nadler
is just trying to fit
uh fit in like us when he said we're not
packing the court we're unpacking it
unpacking it from nine to thirteen come
on bro lol
i tweeted two plus two with seven and
then i replied i'm just trying to fit in
because you saw the two plus two is five
thing i'm not sure
big big push from critical theorists
that two plus two
could actually equal five right okay i'm
pretty sure that's not true
yeah i think all science points are
wrong but uh they can say what they want
i suppose
crinson says back on glocks while the
safety is a drop safety
there is no other safety it's striker
fired so it
so it has no hammer but you can buy a
striker control device that replaces the
backplate to function
like a hammer safety plus oh there you
go
bch broke 900. cheap bitcoin cash
wow there was a period where bitcoin
cash wasn't it like 10 grand or
something
i don't remember it scott like bitcoin
and bitcoin cash
for yeah before and then there was like
no one knew which one was gonna take
over and bitcoin cash skyrocketed and
then fell down and like dropped
dramatically
it just this strikes me as the entire
market is escalating because the u.s
dollar is depreciated
from inflation people want to have
stored value somewhere like they're
trying to
hide it by making go up and down and up
and down but it just keeps going up
keeps and the u.s dollar keeps getting
printed
a lot of comments are talking about
dogecoin like throughout the show people
be like dogecoin
that's right dogecoin is big
peanut butter jelly says doge because
stupid people don't know how to buy xrp
eh dogecoin's funny xrp isn't funny
what am i supposed to laugh about i
invest in things that i think are
are like interesting to me like a cell
phone company or something like that
yeah
i like technology in tesla like electric
cars i have a fraction
i was like whatever i had like some like
20 bucks laying over i was like
you know just whatever yeah but doge is
funny
cancer culture says when will you have
tim dillon on
he is the funniest comedian on earth i
don't think we will have tim dillon
probably because he's just too famous
tim i'd like to have dave chappelle on
the show too but my dad would be good
i don't think he'll come on either um
maybe we go down to austin and get
everybody to come do a big show with
everybody well we're planning on doing
that tour so maybe you know
bradley swann says donate to project
veritas they will fight in many ways
in in ways many of us cannot do to our
jobs or life circumstances
find the donate link in one of their
videos and donate to these heroes
there you go bob says i googled riots
expected tomorrow
and all but the bottom three results
were about the capital
you know have you seen that we did this
on the show we google searched riots
on monday yeah because we just had these
riots and
what comes up the capital trump capital
trump trump trump
we go on bing and we get minnesota we go
on doug
go we get minnesota google is absolutely
filtering out
minnesota but if you google protests
you'll get the the rise
now the reason protest the reason we
know it's google is because
cbs nbc cnn did write about riots
and you can see those articles on bing
and duckduckgo
so that means google was filtering these
out so you couldn't see them
i know google is evil cnn was reporting
on biden wanting to pull troops out but
that trump
had wanted to pull them out by may 1st
and the taliban's like get out by may
1st
biden so cnn kind of transparently
reported on that i didn't expect them to
acknowledge that trump wanted us out
uh j.p mcglone said mcloone says tim
duke university in north carolina is
requiring the vaccine for students to
enroll this fall
this affects new and existing students
students who don't want it but want to
finish undergrad are in a tough place
thoughts
college is stupid so if a bunch of
students don't want to get the vaccine
and they don't want to go to school
i don't care i look i think first and
foremost always talk to your doctor
i don't like the idea of mandated
vaccines
however if a private institution like
university wants to
require that then i don't then don't go
there
it's that simple isn't it i look most of
my friends have gotten the vaccine most
the people i think a good
maybe not a good portion of our guests
have all gotten the vaccine a bunch of
conservative guests are like talking
about how they've already gotten it or
getting it
so i'm i'm it's a really weird thing to
see like donald trump talking about
getting to see ivanka trump literally
taking your vaccine selfie
i do think the vaccine selfies are a bit
like you know i rolly
but it is weird that like ivanka
literally is coming out and like get
this
trump sent in an email where he was
furious
that the fda and the cdc pulled the
johnson johnson vaccine who's like i
did this i deserve the credit they're
trying to make me look bad
but there are so many people who are
like not you know they don't want to get
the vaccine
i'll tell you this i believe in freedom
individual liberty you do what you want
if a private business wants to require
it that's where the problem is
because the vaccine passports is the
freaky invasive stuff
but i do think ultimately you got to
talk to your doctor and i think you
should take your doctor's word for
it yeah i mean if you don't trust your
doctor you've got bigger problems you're
taking a doctor's word for it you don't
you know you're not no you're an owner
well you have a pizza dr doctor yeah you
could have multiple doctors you have a
second opinion is still your doctor
well you could go to another doctor
that's your doctor as well yeah yeah
yeah
you go to ten doctors they're all your
doctors yes yes i'm saying
don't trust people on tv or youtube oh
yeah don't take my word for it
trust us talk to your doctor i just i
think what the problem is
private corporations do at a certain
point have a right to say like we don't
want you coming into our institution or
whatever
the issue is when all of society does it
you have this problem
and i'll throw and i think that's where
you might need regulation to defend
rights maybe in the 14th amendment
and i cite the um was it the cuyahoga
river burst on the flames it did yeah
all of these companies were contributing
a little bit of the pollution and saying
it's not me i'm only doing a little bit
and then we were like okay but y'all
can't do it at the same time so it's the
same thing with the vaccine passports
it's fine you know i think if the
company's like you know you should have
a vaccine it's a problem when a regular
person can't buy food
and it's not being treated fairly in
society because of a medical issue right
i'm not talking about anti-vexers i'm
talking about people who are literally
told by their doctors they advise
against the vaccine
for several reasons of which there are
many many reasons not everyone is able
to go out and take every drug
so let me let me um address that this
person's question i
if this is an idea i like to get out
there i've been talking about it since
the 90s
i'm a i'm a big advocate of
degrees by examination basically it's a
way to
basically do something like
homeschooling at the college level
what i really want to to
exist is um and i
i've never seen this before i mean
degrees by examination exist
and they're very cool you can look into
it you know there's
i think it's empire state college in new
york and then um
there's a system also in in new jersey
and
um and other places i think arizona has
a program like this
um but what i would like to see
is a committee of like three or four
um professors who do like a portfolio
examination
and an oral exam and maybe a written
exam
that that comes at the end of a course
of study and then those
people just by themselves independent of
any
institution they declare that
you are you have knowledge that is the
equivalent to a bachelor's degree is
there any reason why
a lot of people would you accept as a as
as the the
uh the ceo of your of your company would
you
accept that as like proof of uh
uh being college educated
uh i don't i don't think proof of
college education means anything
okay so uh i could i you know you know
as a joke i used to tell people that i
had a phd in nuclear
phys physics and they would be like you
do
absolutely from the college of milton
and they'd go oh wow and
they wouldn't ask anything beyond that
so it's my brother actually made that up
and the point is i never said it was an
accredited university
i never said any i never even elaborated
people just assume things are true
it's the stupidest thing to me where
someone's like i got my piece of paper
it's like okay you know what i did
i took i took uh uh two months of a
community college course that cost like
500 bucks
and that now my highest level of
education is some college well you're
thinking about the
value of a college degree differently
than i do you think of it
as a or you seem to think of it anyway
as
having only economic value and i think
it
represents um a certain level of
you know intellectual attainment um in a
particular
subject completely disagree anyway yeah
ought to and does two different things
my experience from people in colleges is
that they're
underwhelming i mean i've gone to i've
gone to mit several times i spoke at mit
for for one special event
in front of a large group of people from
various backgrounds talking about media
technology drones the things we're
applying them to
and it was fascinating to me that the
people at the the you know at mit of all
places who are working on this tech knew
less about this tech than i did as some
random dude
who went out into a parking lot and
bought a drone and hacked it with his
buddy you know
running the sdk through linux and then
screen grabbing to broadcast
and i'm like we just did it and then i i
was really
i was really amazed the first time i
went to mit and i saw their lab
it's cool saw the things they were
building and i was like my buddy does
this in his garage
and he's not spending tens of thousands
of dollars on tuition to do it
that's weird to me yeah you guys are
both making interesting points because i
think it was a comprehensive enough
examination that
elucidated that the person really does
understand this breadth of knowledge
that is almost better than someone that
went to class for four years
sat there barely listened went in wrote
down the test information they
remembered and then forgot it within a
few weeks
yeah so just going there and being there
doesn't necessarily mean you understand
the concept i would love to see
examinations taking precedence
this is why i tell i just said resumes
mean very little to me
send me your portfolio well i mean okay
maybe
for jobs here but in in larger
institutions where
the you know hr has certain requirements
stay away from those jobs don't disagree
but okay
not everybody is going to take your
advice oh they should right now college
degrees in my opinions are evidence to
the contrary of independent thought
the ability to think critically and
solve problems and the reason is
the people who go to college right now
are the ones who are just told by their
parents to do it they don't know why
i think half the statistic is that 50 of
people change their majors
like some ridiculously large number they
don't know what they want to do and so
i prefer to find people who are like i
pursued my dreams and tried to solve
problems on my own i didn't go to
college
because then you're going to have
someone who's a problem solver a thinker
someone who can think critically the
people who i've found when i've when i
when i've worked for various companies
who have college degrees
they just did what they were told well
they're really good at just doing what
they're told but i need people who can
solve
problems and i need quality control i
think there's
there's an important point to be made
here again you're just
thinking and you're not the only of one
most people think of college degrees
this way and the value of a college
education this way it's
basically an economic transaction
i think you're misunderstanding me okay
people are supposed to go to college to
learn how to think critically and
and and develop intellectuals and some
do some
but most don't and so the issue is fine
well then that's the criticism
in mind it's the criticism isn't a
criticism of
college per se it's of how college is
pursued today
i don't like how it's pursued today
absolutely whereas
as a former college professor myself i
i remember people at ohio state and
columbus state and
no no offense against the people who go
to those institutions they're very smart
actually but it's they they
did not they had no motivation
to better their minds and to to get a
liberal arts education that
means something important when people
who go to these institutions they don't
even
realize what it means and so here's the
issue
okay uh i used to love playing match at
the gathering
i now say i hate the game and don't play
it
because the game's bad because i spanked
them like a hundred times at it no the
game the game's bad they they the power
creep has gone insane
that is the uh it's it's become boring
and people use essentially crowdsourcing
to solve the games as soon as they're
made it's just not
fun anymore net decking yeah netdecking
it's just
competition has become boring the the
win ratios are predictable
it's just become very boring and then
you have new cards coming out that are
just insane power creep
i'm not gonna say and be like no no
magic the other thing's great because of
what it used to be well it's not that
anymore
college may have been a place where you
could show up and learn and explore and
experience but it's not been that way
since my entire life it has never been
that well
this is actually one of the reasons why
i am
pushing young people i occasionally do
this on my blog and i've been talking to
my sons about it too
um that that education is
super important it's really important it
isn't important
for educational reasons or sorry for for
for economic reasons
it's important for educational reasons
for for uh
developing your mind it actually makes
life more interesting it's
it's um and it's it's hard to explain
why this is why knowledge is important
having it in your head not just in a
place to look it up
knowledge a having a systematic
understanding
of the world is important i i
give you an example of how i think about
this right
so i started reading the bible and i've
read it through
all the way through twice in in the last
uh i guess 15 months or so i'm starting
again
and i'm also like reading commentaries
and stuff i'm actually getting into it
um i'm i'm i'm doing reading a little
bit
on the side obviously um that is uh
very similar to the the reading that
that
one would get at seminary i've
absolutely
no motivation no desire to go to
seminary i have talked to a few seminary
professors
though and they're actually um
interested
in in my whole proposal of like
saying you know declaring uh sanger to
have like
a master of divinity degree in five
years after you've gone through
these you know texts and written certain
things and
and that sort of thing i think that
would be um
and but the reason i'm doing it is not
so that i can like
do anything with the degree it's other
than
so but we agree on that okay oh
good but you're not saying these things
that i am sorry well
so you're saying that you're not going
to seminary but you're learning anyway
that's my point why go to college to
learn things you don't have to go to
college to learn
but you're doing this the kind of work
that one
does at going to college
so so if somebody college type study is
still important
do you agree college type study and what
does that mean
reading difficult books thinking deep
thoughts about them having
meaningful discussions with other people
about them writing long papers
doing research that's just studying it
doesn't happen
sure so if someone wanted to learn how
to because
you haven't answered my question is it
important or not studying is important
okay good yeah the the idea that college
can [ __ ]
college is bad as an institution
everything it represents
is a corruption of the uh of these ideas
there may be some positive aspects
within these institutions but they are
overwhelmingly corrupt
the re the really the best way i can
explain it is there's a lot of good
people even today
at in in colleges and i don't i don't
support
a lot of the institutions very much but
i i
it needs to be said that there's a lot
of people who
they're they don't want to lose their
jobs you know and they're still
decent even some of them are even
conservative or libertarian
simple question would you learn more
about journalism
going to college or hanging out in my
house
you'd learn different things for sure
you would learn more about journalism
hanging at my house than you would in
college
you know how i know okay because i've
actually been called to speak at
numerous colleges sure and it's amazing
when i was a 25 year old high school
dropout with a backpack and i was called
to give elec guest lectures for phd
for phd courses in journalism and they
had no idea
any of the modern components of
journalism was fascinating oh they could
tell me things about you know
like woodward and bernstein and i was
like is that relevant to today's modern
understanding of how journalism newsroom
newsrooms operate about how to gather
news how to disseminate information how
to be a journalist
so i i i'm out here you know i'm 25 and
i was consulting with the bbc
sitting down with their mobile experts
explaining to them like what to do how
to do it
universities were asking me to go and
speak there and there's this idea among
people that they're better off going and
going to these schools and spending tons
of money instead of literally just
going and doing journalism and being
surrounded by the experts
in the field the value of being here
would be they would learn faster
because of the mentorship and college
the one-on-one
yeah it's supposed to simulate
mentorship you have a professor that
you're mentoring with but
it's become so big it's the education
industry
that they've even industrialized it is
the problem i have with it
but it's a money-making machine now look
look there's a distinction that needs to
be made here
though right because you're talking
about professional training
and i actually happen to agree with you
i'm not you're referring that i'm
talking about if you want to have a
modern understanding of journalism
outside of any doing a job i didn't say
work here i said
hang out here no no no but
i i understand but but the this is all
in the context of discussion about the
value of
uh college education and your point
seems to be
that learning in the context of uh
you know on the job basically um
i got to stop you i didn't say work here
okay no no okay right so someone who's
literally sleeping on my couch will
learn more about journalism than someone
in a college
okay yeah i kind of have nothing to do
with work because they're going to hear
conversations about the president of cnn
high-level staffers at various news
organizations they're going to see
various top-level journalists who will
be hanging out here and telling them
stories
as opposed to going but they will not
get is a liberal arts education
what does that mean well a liberal arts
education
it has a number of different components
in which basically
you systematically develop an
understanding of the world
through a study of the great books um
and uh why wouldn't they get that well i
don't know dude the people who work here
like often read like homer and yeah i
think we have like three thousand books
no joke
we get sent we get sent like dozens of
books every week and we have tons of
bookshelves with classics
pretty sure we do i was just handed the
art of war for instance
and we've got a bunch of different
versions of the bible if you don't want
to read well
here's this yours is a very unusual
workplace then i guess
it's not about it's not about work
they're like it's it's something you
know a lot of
everyone here is doing something but for
the most part we get books sent here
some of their are insane some of them
are classics
some of them are modern some of them are
old some of them
are ancient philosophy and they're all
here on the bookshelves available for
people to read
it's great my head is off i think that's
that's great so what's the point of
going
spending tens of thousands of dollars to
be surrounded by other people with no
experience and hang out with people with
no experience
to be mentored by someone who has
limited experience who's going to tell
you to read a book
it's the structure like here at this
house you have to seek it
to find it it's not there's no classes
to go to there's no like expectation
of you but at college there's someone
there waiting for you they're they're
giving you a place to be
a seat to sit in and they're focused on
so you're saying unmotivated people will
somehow understand these concepts while
being told they have to do it
actually yeah i mean basically
unfortunately like it or not
um students need
a structure that is imposed by their uh
by their parents or their teachers or
professors
um and uh that's that's the way most
people
are like it or not i mean and i i wish
that
people were like motivated to
do a lot of extracurricular activities
you know bettering their minds as
they are like uh working
near your office or whatever that'd be
that'd be great if the world worked that
way but for the most part it doesn't
so the so the results of taking
unmotivated people who
often not not every i'll put it this way
not everybody has the ability
to to reach the levels you're describing
we we live
in there's a reality some people are
smart some people are average some
people are not smart
some people are strong some people are
tall i heard this really great article
years ago
it was uh it was actually i believe was
from a professor who said
the challenge with universities is that
when unmotivated people go to these
schools because their parents told them
to instead of
learning and truly understanding what
their what they're being told to learn
they simply memorize details
the problem with memorizing details as
opposed to understanding is that they
then start to mash things in a broken
way
you know the saying is not uh
knowledge is knowing that tomato is a
fruit wisdom is knowing that it doesn't
go in a fruit salad
the problem is if you take unmotivated
people and you put them in a room and
you say tomatoes are fruit they'll go
okay
and then later on in life they'll go
tomatoes of fruit put in the fruit salad
motivated people who are dedicated and
passionate will sit there and they'll
understand and say
tomato is a fruit huh then why do we
call it a vegetable
then you'll go through culinary you'll
start researching you'll learn about
different you know culinary arts and
you'll go
wow and then you'll understand
unmotivated people being put in a box
where someone tells them to read a book
doesn't mean they'll understand it or
they want to understand it well i agree
but there's a lot of people who are
inspired
to become uh to better themselves
essentially to better their minds when
they go to college that's just a fact
it's happened
a lot i'm i'm worried that because a lot
of people
are are listening to you and i
understand i think i understand
what you're saying i've heard a lot of
it um
they're going to take your advice and
and they're going to end up being
anti-intellectual frankly and that's not
a good thing
so let me let me show you this research
is anti-intellectual
let me show you this i'm going to give
you this um unless you put in the
library
okay sure okay so i this is essays on
free knowledge
i i wrote it one of my most
controversial
um blog posts is in here
um it's called is there a new geek
anti-intellectualism
the things that you've been saying are
in this article
i i uh basically responded to it it's
from
2011. um and uh
i i would love to have your feedback on
that and and also there's there's a
follow-up where i have
replies to objections is there like
hundreds and hundreds of objections and
it
it generated all kinds of controversy as
uh
you know bloggers responded are you of
the opinion that
independent study and research is
anti-intellectual no no no
this is how we got under this subject of
course it's it's uh
it's perfectly intellectual it's a a
great thing
so um what i want to do is reform the
university system
or force it in one way or another to
reform so it
recaptures its old spirit of true
knowledge seeking um where there is
there is not uh there are not
essentially
doctrinal or ideological tests
for for participating in the system that
that bothers me i think that's a huge
part of the
problem um but like
discouraging people from going to
college
is going to be interpreted whether you
intend it this way or not
i think it's going to be interpreted by
a lot of people as saying
the sorts of things that one learn in
college
are not important i know that's not such
a saying
but from my understanding is i think
from talking with him a lot about this
it's that the things you learn in
college aren't worth the cost the modern
cost of college fiscally because
i actually agree with that but but it's
more than that and people are being
indoctrinated and you get the 99.4
of the people that want to go work for a
firm instead of start their own company
that end up
going there and becoming part of the
machine i
i i've spent a lot of time at various
universities
throughout my life and boy did i find it
laughable
i lived with so many people who spent so
much money going to college
and it was remarkable to me how i could
sit in a room with people
and explain to them basic concepts you'd
think a freshman in college would have
learned that they don't understand
how i could have sat down with a music
business a third year music business
major who had no
idea how she'd not read homer she didn't
know what the word solipsism meant
and she didn't know how to manage bands
and i said then why are you in college
oh that's what college was breeding in
chicago
so maybe your experience you know the
way you viewed college is this positive
thing that needs to be brought back
the way i see it is it's corrupted and
so encouraging people to go into
corruption won't improve it
if the system is reformed then maybe
later we can say hey this is actually
good go do this
however technology maybe has made the
whole institution archaic
you look at the story of someone like
aaron swartz who helped contribute to
the foundation of reddit
as well as uh i think um wasn't he
involved in rss or no no i'm sorry
creative commons
he was he was like 13 and he was on the
internet right he got involved with very
prominent
i remember him i had some interactions
with him back in the day so
how do we encourage young people to be
inspired to get involved to
to seek out on their own college does
the opposite of that
today it beats people down and dulls
them and makes them
hate these things maybe not completely
but
in a very large way and then they come
out with massive debt they become
indentured servants
and many of them because of the
hopelessness become communist
yeah no jeez i i agree with all of that
entirely i don't know what we agree on
is
we want to encourage people to read the
classics to read philosophy
to understand these deep questions and
thoughts
but it's not going to happen or we can
agree on that now my opinion is
college is corrupted siphons money
makes people disinterested and leaves
them as angered indentured
servants yeah so it's a bad thing well i
would disagree with that
i do believe that it makes people
indentured um i didn't go
i've been to college 20 years ago so
it's probably maybe it's changed but i
learned a lot
and i would pay that debt thrice over to
have that experience again
so what if you hung out at hackerspace
instead i guess i don't disagree in my
own case yeah
what if what if we just turn the local
libraries into hacker spaces and you can
go and hang out for free oh that'd be
such a good
use of libraries right so the issue is
technology the books are still there
of course okay and the internet so i
i hung out i hung out at various uh
man i traveled around i met a lot of
different interesting people i
had access to the internet so i was able
to read and research well that's how a
lot of people do use
libraries i go and do work in libraries
sometimes
so we can abolish college but
re-center libraries as the centers for
inquiry investigation research knowledge
seeking
but also activities yeah
libraries are amazing i love libraries i
used to use them all the time when i was
a kid get access to the internet rent
movies
people don't know this i used to go to
the library because they had free movies
to rent
and i would get books movies and i would
go on the internet now what we can do is
create community centers where people
have fun hanging out with each other
exploring ideas
and you could have people come to the
libraries and perhaps
teach these people and you could have a
subscription model where each of these
we'll call them students would learn
from these teachers but pay them
twenty dollars a class via paypal cut
out the middleman no no they're free
this is precisely what i've been
advocating teachers what do you say
what since what is trying to do is cut
out the middleman of college and just
have a teacher directly libraries are
free and there's no schedule
but there's no structure there's no
professors you show up
and richard is there and he's machining
rocket parts
and you go and you go what's he doing
machining rocket parts and then he talks
to you about rocketry
and then one guy's reading a book on
philosophy aristotle
and then kids are are going around
they're they're they're being mentored
by people who are talking about
interesting it's just a scaling problem
because if too many people are
surrounding the rocketry guy and he
doesn't have time to work on his product
or another that's true for
exactly so we've got a media for the
scaling problem i think that's why you
want to pay them
community centers where people can
explore and expand
and engage in practical uh activities
now
i will stress there are absolute
important reasons for college and that's
literally the sciences where
you have to do these things under
regulated conditions if you want to be a
lawyer or a doctor and you have to have
certain credentials
yes college exists for those reasons so
let me uh let me ask you first
uh have you heard of um
different homeschooling philosophies
like um
uh a classic um
method and and uh unschooling and these
different home schools i've heard of the
preschoolers i know the girl dana martin
so let me let me sort of i actually
think we agree
a lot more than we disagree but you
basically want
your model your mental model for
education is essentially
unschooling my mental model for
education
is it makes room for that for people for
whom
it is good but it isn't good for most
people
most people need more structure my sons
would not thrive
under an unschooling uh model they
simply wouldn't learn the things that
they
should learn i'm not advocating for an
unschooling system i'm saying there are
benefits to converting libraries into
hacker spaces
because hacker spaces are greatly
beneficial i think there's many
different ways people learn some people
learn
through physically grasping an object
and rotating it some people learn
through hearing from another
person or through reading through
demonstration
those are not the things that are
relevant to the to the controversy
between us here that right
that's relevant is does it does the
education
need to be regimented from
above by some
leader of the curriculum because look
there's some people who really want to
learn they have a hard time motivating
themselves and they actually want the
direction
they they need the direction and they
really would
they really would benefit too so so
i'm not saying we don't have teachers
i'm saying the current
institution of college is a broken down
old rusty pile of garbage
that you can't polish well but there's
i think if you're going to appeal to all
the people
that we need to appeal to they're going
to serve
if we're going to serve all of their
needs
then there's going to be something like
college that emerges even if it is like
decentralized
and so forth but but i think the issue
is there's a reason why the left targets
children
they don't need to appeal to the old
people yeah the old people walk away and
the young people do
what the generation was told to do yeah
so what we need to do is we need to
inspire young people
i appreciate the book you got to sign
that we yeah absolutely sign it okay we
need to inspire young people to
be seekers to be hackers to be
interested
and to achieve things and there's
probably some people who can't do it and
they need direction
but a lot a lot of what i see happening
is that young people are not
being properly educated and motivated
notably that in america we don't teach
children anything before the age of five
which is insane to me like from zero to
five
right the most important i taught my
boys to read
both when they were one they they knew
how to read picture books
uh by the age of two and they were
reading chapter books when they were
three
and the problem is most most americans
don't do anything until they're five
which is which is ridiculous yeah and
they loved it too by the way i didn't
force them right at all
because kids want to learn it's it's
literally
within humans to try and like they
always say kids will imitate you because
they're trying to learn
so teach these kids things and
congratulate them and make them feel
good
the one thing that will really help
people be inspired is if you've got a
little kid
and they go in and they're you know
doing something positive
and you cheer them on and other people
are like wow this kid's cool they're
gonna feel
good from the social acceptance it will
encourage them to pursue doing good
things
however what we do in this country is we
don't teach our kids until they're five
then they start learning rudimentary
basics i mean i'm sure parents to some
degree teach their kids some things
obviously
but then they basically go to an
institutionalized learning facility
where many teachers
are just not good at what they do many
of them are mean
i think i had two good teachers in my
life two
and there's a phrase that i think breaks
down exactly what's wrong with schooling
school sucks why would kids say that why
why is it that i can be so inspired i
built my first computer when i was like
eight years old
why because i had good parents they they
taught me before five they inspired me
they cheered me on they talked about how
amazing these things were and i wanted
to do these amazing things
many other kids were riding around on
their bikes careless and so all they
wanted to do was get social acceptance
from their friends who also were riding
around on their bikes
having fun i wanted to do things i
wanted to play music i wanted to
skateboard i wanted to accomplish things
so how do we get kids to do that we need
to create
a new culture of inspiration
of hands-on activities having kids
feel good when they accomplish something
what you're describing here sounds like
just
what our educators are taught in in
progressive
education um uh
institutions and have been for the last
hundred years
um uh so yeah they
they're like vigorously nodding their
head
um to to the suggestion that we need
hands-on education
that that um they they need to get out
there and actually build things
and it comes from the parents and um
yeah they need inspiration
um they don't need indoctrination they
uh
you know less reading of books and more
were
making and doing i didn't say lessons
well that's what they say
and then they regard it as as well but
they really they regard it all
of a piece you see um this is why it's
so easy
i think and if you read the essay
that i was referring to there about
about geek anti-intellectualism
um you'll you'll see why um
and uh so like i i have a feeling
that uh like you don't have kids right
yeah well i mean when you have kids
you're probably going to be
homeschooling dad
i'm guessing um it could be a very
interesting curriculum
i hope so monday morning from 9 to 10 is
parkour hour
time no no no i'm sorry that's
commanding then it's going to be
brazilian jiu jitsu all right so the
first is just to get loosened up to
climb around to get that agility and
then the next hour is the
brazilian employees and then uh you can
earn crypto from your math class
so i think gamifying education is going
to be the wave of the future
because if you can earn crypto even if
it's just like non-fungible
tokens that are worth anything but you
can spend on like um
a hat for your avatar and then you're
rather than riding around and showing
your friends how cool you are outside
you'll
go to class and be like yo i don't need
video games because look how good i am
at
my class you can see it my son has
actually stopped
playing some of his io games
um in favor of trading uh crypto
you're agreeing with me oh yeah when i'm
saying it's the dopamine hit
yes getting kids to get that dopamine
hit a goal was accomplished yeah
the problem i see is that many many
parents don't do anything with their
kids
until so the kids don't develop this you
know this mindset
but anyway yeah we've gotten very very
long rewarding oh yeah i guess we have
this has been absolutely wonderful uh
thanks for for hanging out and talking
about wikipedia i really appreciate you
coming larry absolutely
for everybody who's uh watching we're
not gonna have an extended uh bonus
segment tonight consider this the extra
half an hour
segment yeah awesome free bonus segment
for everybody and i it was interesting
we we rolled with it
and um but we are gonna have more vlogs
coming up because we do have one we're
ready to publish
we're just there there's like some some
bumps we're gonna get through probably
might be up like a saturday or sunday
thing
we're gonna start filming these we need
a master of ceremonies email us at
jobscast.com
if you think you have what it takes i'll
put it this way mc probably got to be
able to
play music and skateboard because you're
going to be helping produce these vlogs
so
and we're also looking for a web dev and
web editor but
you can follow me on every social media
platform at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday the friday at
8pm so subscribe smash that notification
bell hit the like button it's all
greatly appreciated
and did you want to shout out anything
larry mentioned maybe your book or
social media follow you um sure okay
well um
okay go ahead and buy my book please um
i don't think you're intending i'm
talking um
it's it's uh it's on uh amazon the ebook
is
also on gum road and amazon um
it's called essays on free knowledge the
origins of wikipedia and the new
politics of knowledge
and um a lot of things that we've talked
about
actually are in this book especially in
the last new chapter
um the future of the free internet cool
um and then thank you for the book
yeah sure um i i want to encourage
people who are
interested in the encyclosphere project
especially
if if you're technical even if you're
not and you're just interested in the
stuff
um sign up uh we're starting a seminar
slash deliberation about the policies of
the future
um in cyclosphere uh probably beginning
next month i hope
um no promises uh but it's gonna be free
donations are um encouraged
uh and it's going to be serious we're
going to have like bill ottman
uh he's already agreed to uh talk uh in
in our
the week that we're gonna do about
decentralizing social media
um and uh so
sign up for that seminar sign up for the
encyclosphere it's in
psyclosphere.org just like it sounds
and um well i've got a lot of other
things called
social media you have social media
accounts too right you have lisa twitter
elsanger on twitter um
and you can like follow my rss feed
feeds actually larrysanger.org
and then i have my micro feed and that
actually the future the future um name
for it actually is going to be the
mini feed that's what it's going to be
minifeed um
as it lives on start this google.org
right on very cool really appreciate you
coming larry yeah absolutely and i'm
looking forward to working with you in
cyclosphere
yeah involving that in this vetoverse uh
more and more man um
you guys can follow me at ian
crossland.net and at ian crossland
across
pretty much every social media platform
so hit me up there if you ever want to
message me or anything and get involved
thanks good
super fun conversation thank you for
coming larry i feel like i learned a lot
even though this is way out of my field
of expertise
i am sarah patch lids on twitter and
join me on my quest to have more
followers in the actual sour patch kids
account we'll have fun with that
we will see you all tomorrow but don't
forget to sign up at timcast.com become
a member because we have a lot of really
cool stuff in the works thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time bye guys
you